Oh,
hello freaks.
Yes,
we are back again.
Did you miss us now?
You couldn't have missed us.
We've been doing this shit all week.
This is ridiculous.
He's the longest run a podcast ever from me with his four of them in the top 10
right now.
Yeah.
Four out of this.
That's crazy.
We have four podcasts.
That sounds like bragging.
A lot of pressure for me.
No cause no pressure.
Dr. Patrick,
we're not.
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience is brought to you by stamps.com do you
remember back in the days of black and white TVs and phones with wires,
the only way of business could avoid the post office was to least a postage
meter.
That's annoying,
but today technology has made it so that anyone can have that possibility at
your home.
All you need is stamps.com
that's coffee with stamps.com you can print official us postage from your home
or office computer right from your desk.
Just Bang.
Just measure it out.
Print it out with a free digital scale that they provide and you print out
official US postage.
Mailman comes,
takes it.
You avoid all the lines of the post office official US postage for any letter,
any package using your computer and printer,
no extra hardware to buy or lease.
And unlike a meter,
there are no long term commitments and you can save up to 80% versus a meter
plus a stamps.com you can track packages,
track spending and more.
We use stamps.com Thompson during Christina [inaudible],
stamps.com Brian red band uses stamps.com to send out the desk squad.tv tee
shirts that he sells.
And with this no risk trial using the Promo Code j r e you will get a $110 bonus
offer,
which includes a digital scale and up to $55 of free postage.
So do not wait.
Go to stamps.com and before you do anything else,
click on the old school microphone in the upper right hand corner and type in j
r e that stamps.com and enter j r e save yourself some money and that's the only
God damn commercial we're doing today.
How about that?
Cue The music.
Young Jamie,
talk to Rhonda.
Patrick is here.
We're going to find this some shit out about health.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day
low.
Rhonda.
Hello Joe.
You're the only person that's ever come in and sat down and said,
oh,
this is good.
I'm getting a cortisol rush.
She,
he said you're getting a cortisol rush from the,
the feeling of about to do a pilot.
Actually,
I could have gone a little more detail,
but I was like,
please do.
Yeah.
You know,
so that feeling of anxiety,
you know,
that like you get before you got on stage,
I mean,
you're a comedian.
Sure.
You're really familiar with that.
You actually are expressing a chemical called dynorphins and uh,
this,
this is an endogenous chemical in your brain and it binds to something called
the Kappa opioid receptor.
It's kind of like the counter of the endorphin,
which binds to the Mu opioid receptor.
So the endorphins are the field.
Good.
Well,
it's nemesis is the diner fin,
which is that anxiety,
like feeling.
So,
but here's the interesting part,
that anxiety,
like feeling that you feel before you're,
you know,
going to do something like you're really,
that you care about or that's kind of anxiety provoking for me.
Public speaking does it,
I get it right before I'm going to do it,
you know,
give a talk or something or do a podcast in front of,
500,000 people.
Um,
so that dynorphins binding to the kappa opioid receptor,
what it does is it up regulates the mule opioid receptor.
So that after you get that anxiety feeling,
you have a better endorphin rush because you upregulate the new opioid
receptors,
which bind to the endorphins,
the feel good ones,
and you actually become sensitized to them.
So there's a biological mechanism by which having that anxiety actually does you
good.
So it's,
it's kind of like a stress at first,
but then later on you're,
you get,
you feel better and you're more relaxed.
That's what you know.
That's interesting because one of the best feelings ever is after you compete.
Like when you fight,
one of the things that people get addicted to is um,
you get addicted to the rush for sure.
The adrenaline rush and you get addicted to the,
just the,
the challenge of competition being life magnified on such an incredible scale
that everything else seems kind of Pale in comparison.
But the big addiction I think is the feeling that you get after you compete,
especially if you win.
There's just amazing feeling like life is incredible.
He just like the ground feels better under your feet,
the colors in the trees look better,
everything looks better for a couple of days.
I totally know what you're talking about.
And there's a biological mechanism for that and it's interesting because it's
also the same mechanism that occurs when you are working out really hard.
I mean it's painful while you're doing it,
but the more pain you experience,
the better the rush that it's the endorphin high people talk about.
It's actually that that mechanism is anxiety inducing.
Stress inducing is an important factor in that because of this mechanism I
talked about where you up regulate those receptors that bind to the endorphins
and you become in your sensitizing them so they become more sensitized to them.
So it's a heat does the same thing.
Heat stress.
So you know,
exercise,
capsaicin.
So eating spicy food,
it's painful while you're eating it.
But what happens is there's your upregulating,
those,
those Mu opioid receptors,
and you're sensitizing them to the endorphins,
which is why you feel really good after eating spicy food.
Oh,
that's what that is.
I never knew what that was.
That's interesting because I always thought it just tasted good,
like a kind of a weird,
cool,
good spicy taste.
I'm sure there's dopamine responses and all that stuff
involved.
Um,
I mean there's,
you know,
complex mechanisms and things going on in your brain,
but when you're eating or when you pleasure,
when you enjoy a certain taste of a food,
but this particular mechanism where you've got this dynorphins and Endorphin,
you know,
connection.
Um,
it's really interesting and I think it's something I discussed on a recent
article that I wrote about the sauna.
So,
uh,
I hope people find it interesting cause I think it's interesting,
isn't it,
what it is to know about it.
It is,
it's gotten some really good responses to I've a,
I've read it and I've read a lot of the responses that people find it pretty
fascinating when you were talking about it in the podcast,
but it's kind of almost like the Yin and Yang of life is what you're talking
about here.
It's like you need to have some negative in order to feel some extra positive,
right?
No,
the,
uh,
are you familiar with [inaudible]?
Okay.
Um,
I know I've heard the term but I couldn't describe it if somebody asks me
like,
so what it means,
you mean?
Yes.
Okay.
So [inaudible] what it really refers to is having a little bit of stress,
something that's a little toxic for you,
something that's a little stressful on your body.
I mean,
exercise for sure is that he is a little stressful things in some of the foods
we eat.
Like the Eeg,
cgs and green tea are polyphenols and some of the fruits and also in red wine.
These things are actually a little bit toxic to our body.
And what happens is that this induces,
um,
stress response mechanisms in our body.
The activation of a whole host of jeans,
like you know,
antioxidant genes,
glutathione peroxidase,
things like,
um,
you know,
he'd shocked factors which do a variety of different things.
So a little bit of stress activates this whole stress response mechanism in our
body.
And then what happens is now we can deal with stress better.
So it's,
it's kind of like interesting to think about adding a little bit of something
that's toxic to,
you know,
get
a better response.
So that's fascinating.
You were talking about that last time we were here about mycotoxins that in fact
Michael Toxins in a small dose might induce that sort of,
yeah.
I mean I totally made,
I was wet hand waving.
I haven't read anything.
Get you allowed to do that when your hand waving.
I'm like,
well actually maybe it makes sense that in a small dose,
I mean,
obviously you don't want something that's like very toxic and I'm gonna kill
your brain cells or anything like that.
But uh,
things in small doses.
And I was assuming that maybe mycotoxins could possibly have a little slight
hormetic effect.
Um,
you know,
like I said,
I that was just me theorizing.
Uh,
you know,
so,
but
fascinating though that that is sort of the way like,
especially when it comes to exercise that you need to experience this like
intense hardship in order to get this wonderful feeling of accomplishment,
this endorphin rush.
And this,
I feel so good after I work out.
Like I,
I make all my best decisions after I have a really good workout and it's just
like my body has a perspective.
I have a better perspective if I haven't worked out in a couple of days and I'm
stressed and,
and then I have to make a decision.
Oftentimes I don't trust my,
Oh yeah.
I'm
the same way.
I'm absolutely addicted to the feeling and the physiological changes that occur
with exercise.
And there are a lot of them that are occurring,
um,
you know,
in the brain and,
and elsewhere.
Uh,
but it's the same,
you know,
it's what's really kind of fascinating recently,
we,
you know about inducing neurogenesis when you work out that's kind of well known
where exercise induces the growth of new brain cells.
BDNF is one way.
Igf One,
these things can,
you know,
you grow new brain cells.
And so growing new brain cells has always been associated with um,
uh,
learning and memory.
It's like,
oh,
you're grown.
You grow new brain cells.
And they've shown that that neurogenesis in adults at least as associated with
new learning,
a new memory.
But what they found recently,
and I found this really interesting,
um,
because it kind of changed the way I think of it,
uh,
is that when you grow those new brain cells,
like when you're exercising,
um,
heat stress does the same thing actually.
So getting in the sauna,
when you're exercising your heat stress in your body,
I mean,
your core body temperature is elevated.
It's in a very similar,
um,
so what happens is you grow new brain cells and these new brain cells have to
make new connections with other neurons.
And so what ends up happening is that other connections that you made with
north,
so the connections you make between neurons,
the synapses that your form memories,
it's things that you can remember,
right?
I mean you make you form these synopses and that's like a piece of information
remembered.
Or in some cases it's uh,
an experience that you had that you remember well you actually change those
synopses and some of them go away.
So you kind of forget to make room for a new neuron to make a new.
So it,
it,
it really is interesting how also you have this connection,
but it's,
it's a balance where you're forgetting a things that you're,
you're totally disconnecting some connections between old neurons that you had
previously made for whatever thing you had learned or,
and you're making room for this new neuron that just was born to make a new
connection and make learn something new.
So,
uh,
do you have that balance again?
It's just,
you know,
it's,
it seems like a very important biological mechanism.
This,
this mean and Yang where it's like there's,
there's stress and then there's the,
the response to the stress,
which is good.
And you know,
there's things like,
you know,
forgetting things but so that you can learn new things.
I mean it's kind of an important,
can you imagine if you remembered everything you've ever
go insane.
Yeah,
I have a real problem with that.
I have a real problem with having too much information in my head and then
forgetting things at other people remember and they'll,
they'll remember it like it was this big important thing and I'm like,
what did we really do that?
I don't remember that.
And it's just because I've had too many experiences.
Like there's too much stuff.
Or if you go back to talk to someone,
you went to high school with people that don't leave,
that are stuck in that town and they can remember,
remember when we were 17 and we did that crazy thing.
You're like,
no,
I don't fucking remember that.
Like,
how do you remember that?
Like him,
you got to get out of this town,
man,
you're to make some new connections in your brain,
son.
Yeah,
I know that that's a,
you're right
into what's called episodic memory,
which is the,
the type of memory that's associated with experiences.
And that's,
there's a lot of different things that can regulate that.
One.
One would be like a very strong emotional response.
Like you're Mcdilla is activated.
So if something you'll probably remember things that are fear inducing or
something that's really exciting,
really,
really exciting to you.
You know,
that those sorts of things can solidify those types of connections.
So,
uh,
also have serotonin plays a role in that,
whether it was a really,
yeah,
I,
I've been doing this other paper that I've been working on.
Um,
I've been looking at the role of Serotonin in brain function and dysfunction and
also behavior,
but,
uh,
it seems like serotonin plays a role in executive function and specifically an
episodic memory.
So,
so,
um,
any episodic memory that has a big rush of Serotonin,
would it be because what would,
what,
what would cause that specifically?
Like what would make a serotonin rush and a memory.
Yeah.
I think,
I mean there's a lot of different things that are at serotonin release is
happens to a variety of different factors,
but one,
one could actually be a very potent,
something that's very potent that you're experiencing.
Do you know,
does that make sense?
Where it's like,
it's not just your everyday stuff that you kind of block out,
like it's just routine,
but it's something just novel.
And would that be like
the day you find out that Kennedy got shot or the day nine 11 happened or the
daily extreme events,
what response would that be?
I think that would
the Amygdala response.
Yeah.
Where your Amygdala gets activated.
Um,
but I think for the Serotonin it's,
it's,
it's more of a,
they've done a lot of studies where they've looked at kind of like the pleading
it and what happens?
What happens when you don't have,
when you can't make it,
you just,
you're episodic memories bad.
Well,
that's the thing with
people who do a Mtma with people who party too much and do ecstasy.
Is the,
the crush afterwards,
is there serotonin being depleted?
Right.
That's a big part of it.
What's the mechanism of action of MDA?
I our MD m I always forget,
we could pull it up.
Um,
well,
MDM may supposedly has some function with a rushing serotonin into your system
and it gives you this gigantic,
let's see if it gives you a,
uh,
induce euphoria,
sense of intimacy with others.
Diminished anxiety,
mild psychedelia Psychedelia is a weird word.
Doesn't seem like it should be real,
but it is.
And he studies particularly in the fields of psychology and cognitive therapy,
so they use it a lot.
Lately.
It's been used a lot for PTSD,
which is interesting because,
um,
I,
I've only taken it once.
I took it once a long time ago.
I never took it again and never had the desire to take it again.
Although I had a very positive experience with it because the,
the downside,
but the next day was just brutal.
Like I couldn't read.
I was,
I remember I was in a coffee shop and I was trying to read a magazine and I
couldn't focus enough to read a paragraph.
He couldn't focus.
There was nothing going on.
And my brain was just like,
uh,
I,
my brain felt like a dry sponge.
Just some,
some things that happen when you release a lot of Serotonin,
you know,
into your synopsis is that your body,
because there's,
it's too much.
There's more than,
you know,
it's supposed to have,
you'll start to downregulate other receptors and there seems to,
there's like a negative feedback.
So what would happen then is the next day you're not going to be as responsive
to that Serotonin.
Um,
and that's,
that's something that's a big problem with some Ssri drugs and things like that
where you know,
you're,
you're basically preventing the serotonin from being Metabo re metabolized,
taken back up.
And so it sits around and these synapse for a lot longer than it's supposed to
and they've shown that the consequence to that is you actually downregulate
serotonin receptors,
which is what,
you know,
serotonin receptor response to the Serotonin that you're releasing.
So you can't respond to it then,
you know,
what's the point?
So there's a lot of these feedback mechanisms that occur.
Um,
you know,
and I don't even know all of them.
I just,
it's,
it's very complex.
It's listed in Wiki onto the longterm effects that it causes.
A down regulation of Serotonin reuptake transporters in the brain,
the rate at which the brain recovers from serotonergic searching.
So it's an urgent changes is unclear.
Once that demonstrated a lasting serotonergic changes to nurture,
to nurture in some animals exposed to Mtma,
other studies have suggested that brain may recover from the damage.
But um,
a lot of people that do it,
they take five HTP to try to juice up their serotonin.
They ticket while they're doing MTMA and then they take it afterwards.
Yeah,
I have to be really careful when you're combining multiple drugs that are
affecting like Serotonin for example,
or that pathway because then you can end up getting something called,
I think they call it Serotonin Syndrome,
where it's like,
like people that are taking ssrs have to be really careful and not take a bunch
of trip defenders.
You know,
because then you can induce like I toxicity.
That's,
that's pretty dangerous.
And I forget what all the,
you know,
you decide,
you know what all of the,
the actual effects of Serotonin Syndrome are,
but they're,
they're not good.
Yeah.
Not good at all.
That's an issue with people also that are taking five HTP.
If they're on a Serotonin,
a SSRI,
right.
And they take a five HTP,
you can get this serotonin syndrome.
You know,
the other thing about Serotonin,
I mean,
we always think about it as being a brain.
You know,
neurochemical,
right?
A neurotransmitter in the brain,
but actually the majority of the Serotonin in your bodies is not in your brain.
It's made in your gut.
Really.
Yeah.
So actually just published a paper.
It was published the last time I was on this podcast.
Actually,
my paper,
I didn't know it was,
it just came out in press the day that I was on this podcast.
But so,
um,
there's two different genes that they're,
that,
that convert tryptofan into five HTP.
Okay.
That's the rate limiting step where you convert trip to fan into five
hydroxytryptophan and they're called,
that's called Tryptophan
hydroxylase.
Okay.
And there's one enzyme called Tryptophan hydroxylase,
one that's local.
It's local,
localized,
are located outside of the blood brain barrier and it's predominantly found in
the gut,
but it's also found in the pineal gland,
which is actually separated by the blood brain barrier.
It's not,
it's close to the brain,
but it's actually separated.
And it's also found in a seminar t cells and placenta tissue.
But um,
and then there's Tryptophan hydroxylase to which is the brain form.
And that's found in the Dorsal raphe a part,
the mid part of your brain.
And um,
there's,
there's also some expressions.
So your gut has neurons in it as well.
And Terrick neurons,
that enzyme,
that's the neuron one.
There's some of that also in your gut,
but mostly it's the other enzymes.
So there's Tryptophan hydroxylase one Tryptophan hydroxylase too.
They both make serotonin.
So serotonin made in your gut,
um,
actually causes GI inflammation and they've shown this in,
in like mouse models because what happens is serotonin made in the gut,
activates t cells and t cells have a receptor to it on their cell surface.
And when they respond to Serotonin,
they proliferate and grow more.
And so if you're making,
if you have a bunch of Serotonin in your gut,
you can get GI inflammation.
And you know,
this is,
I think this has also been documented with people that take too much five HTP,
um,
as well as,
uh,
people with colitis and such.
They've done mouse models where they knock out that enzyme church of a
hydroxylase,
one that makes serotonin in the gut and it completely ameliorates that the
inflammatory like,
um,
you know,
symptoms in those,
in those mouse models.
So,
um,
the other enzyme in your brain.
So this is where my paper comes in and sort of,
uh,
it's a theoretical paper,
but I found a mechanism.
So with theoretical paper means I didn't actually do any experiments on mice.
I didn't actually do a clinical trial.
I just,
I found an underlying mechanism and I explained it all and found all this stuff
that was buried in the literature and put it all together.
It's actually my first theoretical paper that I've ever written in publishers.
Yeah,
thanks.
So what I found was that these two enzymes for Tryptophan hydroxylase both have
what's called a vitamin D response element in it,
which is a telltale sequence that vitamin D,
when vitamin D binds to a vitamin D receptor,
it recognizes that and it can turn on a gene or it turns off a gene.
And when it turns on gene gene does what it's supposed to do and turns it off,
it's almost like it's not there.
What I found with it is that that,
so the sequence itself of this vitamin D element,
uh,
can determine whether or not it's going to turn it on or off.
And I found these two different enzymes of Tryptophan hydroxylase had a
different response elements.
One wasn't on sick signal and one was an off signal.
The one in the brain was an on signal and the one in the gut wasn't off signal
suggesting that vitamin D was regulating the production of Serotonin in opposite
directions in different tissues.
So you needed it to make it in your brain,
but if you had enough vitamin D,
it would shut off the gut one,
not completely,
but turns it so that you're not making as much serotonin.
You don't have as much Gi inflammation.
And then I related this to autism because I know I'm getting way out there,
but uh,
it's,
it's pretty cool.
So,
uh,
autism has been on the rise.
Like right now.
The most recent CDC report that came out said that one in 68 children have
autism.
I mean,
it's been,
it's risen like 600% since the 1970s.
It's astronomical.
Like how much it's risen.
So they can't really,
they have an identified a genetic,
cause like 70 over 70% of autism cases have not been linked to a genetic
mutation,
which means to me,
something in the environment seems to be going on.
There's something,
something that is,
you know,
interacting with possible genetic mechanisms that's causing this autism rise.
And,
um,
you know,
vitamin D is one thing that's been people getting adequate.
Vitamin D has been on the decrease the same time that autism rises autism's been
rising.
And,
um,
so I came up with this,
this theory that low vitamin D during pregnancy,
um,
and also during the neonate when you're a young child can lead to serotonin
deficiency in the brain.
And what happens is during the brain,
during fetal brain development,
Saratonin is critical to,
um,
guide neurons to where they're supposed to go to make them proliferate.
Uh,
you know,
it's an important differentiation factor to help them make the kind of neurons
they're supposed to make.
It plays a very,
very important role in regulating brain structure and morphology.
What,
what vitamin D in particular?
Because vitamin D three was the one that you were on last time.
Vitamin D three.
So vitamin D three,
the way it works is you can make vitamin D in your skin.
You can see,
you can convert it into d three.
Yeah.
So UVB radiation,
you need UVB light and it converts something.
And your skin called 70 hydro cholesterol into vitamin D three.
And then this gets released into the bloodstream,
goes to your liver where then it's converted to 25 hydroxy vitamin D,
which is what people,
uh,
it's a major circulating form of Vitamin D.
And that's what you get measured when you go,
you know,
get your vitamin D levels measured and then it goes into your kidneys and gets
activated to inactive steroid hormone.
And it's called one 25.
Hydroxyvitamin d.
So vitamin D gets converted into an active steroid hormone.
And once it's converted into that act as to ride home and,
and your kidneys,
what then it does is it binds to a vitamin D receptor in different tissues in
your body,
including your brain.
And it does this thing where it turns on or turns off over a thousand different
genes in your,
in your body.
So it's regulating a lot of,
you know,
different processes.
One of them just to Serotonin.
So I basically came up with this,
this,
this theory that,
you know,
Pete,
women were not getting enough vitamin D and the child's brain was then becoming
serotonin deficiency.
It was changing the structure of the way the brain was developing.
And,
um,
they've,
they've seen now that autism actually it seems be occurring in Utero and they're
finding now they've been doing these studies where they're finding now that it
seems to be a good,
strong environmental component and they haven't figured out what it is.
Um,
so I'm hoping that people will start,
I'm not an autism researcher and I'm not a neuroscientist.
I mean,
I know a little bit about it.
Um,
but what I did was I kind of just took a step back and started putting all these
things together and came up with this hypothesis.
And I also found things like estrogen can activate that same gene in Tryptophan
hydroxylase.
So estrogen can protect you.
If you have low vitamin D,
You can still make that,
that serotonin from tryptophan because estrogen activates that same gene also.
So,
and then the whole gut inflammation thing autistics have this.
And I think that they're,
you know,
they have high gut inflammation cause they have too much.
They have too much serotonin going on in the gut.
That's why the common thing with common with autistic.
Wow,
that's fascinating.
So it's,
it's pretty interesting.
Um,
I totally forgot why I got on this I totally tangent.
When we were talking about Serotonin five HTP five,
right?
So that,
that's another thing where it's like five HTP.
The first thing it does is it hits the gut and you've got that enzyme in there
that can,
uh,
well in the gut.
So Ti five HTP actually bypasses a Tryptophan hydroxylase part.
It,
it's now the next step,
which is to be decarboxylated into serotonin.
So you can actually convert it.
If you take too much of it,
you'll convert it into serotonin in your gut before it gets to your brain.
So it's something to keep him at five [inaudible].
Serotonin does not cross the blood brain barrier.
Um,
five HTP does.
Wow.
So if you're,
if you're converting this serotonin immediately in your gut,
then it's not going to get to your brain.
So there,
there's complex mechanisms.
Just tryptophan cross the blood brain barrier Tryptofan does get transported
into the brain.
Yeah.
And we talked about this a little bit last time where it competes with branch
chain amino acids to get transported into the brain.
So what happens is,
you know,
Lucy ice solution,
these things actually when they both,
because at the same time they're going through the same transporter.
Tryptofan is a very rare amino acid in,
in proteins.
It's much less abundant than branch chain amino acids like leucine.
And I said,
listen,
this is it a myth,
the trip to Fan Turkey thing,
the correlation between eating Turkey and getting tired after you.
I don't think that getting tired after eating it is a myth.
I think it's a myth that it's two to trip defend because actually,
um,
Ma to the penny oil gland.
So the penny old clan converts Serotonin into Melatonin.
Okay.
And the pineal gland is not,
it's not a part of the,
it's separated by the blood brain barrier.
So that competition,
you know,
for the branching amino acids getting into the pineal gland is we're talking
about something different.
So you know,
it,
you probably are getting a little bit of trip to fan being converted to
Melatonin,
Serotonin and Melatonin when you're eating Turkey.
But Turkey,
Turkey has a lot of branch chain amino acids as well.
So
it's most likely just a fat fuck.
It's most likely a,
yeah,
exactly.
You know,
but you said it,
not me stuffing and all the other stuff that goes along with it.
Um,
the other thing you,
the t cells and want to get back to that real quick because you were talking
about the elevated t cell count right now.
Is that something that would help people that have HIV,
um,
would,
uh,
a lot like a high dose of five HTP help people who have HIV that have low t cell
counts.
Does that make sense?
Is it the same thing?
I've never
thought about that.
Um,
I mean,
that's an issue,
right?
With,
with AIDS patients.
I mean,
well,
there's a lot of issues.
Um,
but yeah,
they're,
they definitely do have low t cell.
I,
you know,
I don't know.
That's a really good question,
Joe.
Actually,
I'm pretty impressed that,
that's interesting.
It's possible.
But it seems like five HTP,
you know,
being converted to Serotonin,
the serotonin having an effect on t cell counts only gut level serotonin.
Um,
no,
it hasn't no
effect on peripheral blood t cell counts.
Yeah,
that's why it's actually a pretty fascinating question.
I,
I don't know the answer to,
but certainly something that I think I'll probably look into after this.
Yeah,
that seems like we have some,
we have a supplement that we sell that is a hold on up grab it.
It's in this box right here.
That's five HTP l trip to fan and a couple other things.
It's called new mood.
Yeah.
So basically,
oh,
you got one right here?
Yeah,
that's um,
as an f five HTP supplement that was originally created.
It was originally when we first came up with it.
Uh,
allegedly my friend and partner allegedly likes to do ecstasy,
allegedly.
And he came up with this,
uh,
they called it roll off.
And the idea would be when you came off of,
you know,
when people do Mtma they call it rolling and when you're off the Mtma,
you're like,
oh well that was the nutritional boost that you needed to get your brain to
produce more five HTP or to produce more serotonin rather.
Actually what's really interesting as I look at this is that you have vitamin D
three in it.
Yes.
Which really surprises me because whoever made this connection,
but for putting the vitamin D and with the El Tryptofan I'm pretty impressed
because that until my paper was published in February,
no one had known that vitamin D can Reg.
I mean I'm sure.
I don't know whoever made that connection.
That's an interesting,
that's interesting that you were able to figure out to put vitamins,
Ia with Alitrip defend cause I haven't seen any supplement on the market that's
done that.
I mean,
I don't know if you,
whoever did this knew,
but um,
because because tryptofan you know,
you need vitamin D to convert Tryptophan into serotonin.
So that's actually pretty,
yeah.
Interesting.
Well,
my partner,
Aubrey,
who's also my good friend is very,
uh,
he's very diligent when it comes to the research involved in any of these
supplements.
And he's also been a freak about vitamins and nutrients like his entire life.
His mother's a maniac when it comes to that stuff.
He learned a lot of it from her.
And then extensive research.
But yeah,
we,
I mean,
we made sure that we were putting something like that out.
We wanted to make sure that we had all the bases covered.
Now that's kind of cool that the vitamin D's in there,
I wouldn't have expected that the,
the pineal gland is a fascinating gland that the fact that that is what creates
so many different elements that regulate mood and that also,
now,
I don't know if you're familiar with this,
there's this,
um,
there's always been this thing about dimethyltryptamine,
which is the psychedelic drug that's produced by the brain.
It's also produced by the liver and the lungs while they've,
they've found recently,
like within the last year,
uh,
evidence that it's produced by the pineal gland.
It's always been like this big,
um,
sort of,
uh,
there was,
there was anecdotal evidence,
but there was never real hard evidence until they,
they actually showed that in live mice,
the pineal gland is producing dimethyltryptamine and that's the third eye.
I mean the pineal gland,
you know,
in reptiles.
So it's producing it when you sleep or well it's producing it during different
periods of stress during rem sleep.
Um,
but they,
you know,
it's hard to get a brain,
um,
hard to get a mouse to sleep or you got to fucking big saw mark on its brain or
a,
an opening in his brain and your testing.
It's pineal gland.
So the amount of evidence they have about humans,
but when and where is a,
is kind of limited.
But now they're making these,
correlating,
they,
they're,
they're making a correlation based on the Mammo,
based on them and the mice,
but they're trying to do more studies on human beings,
more accurate studies and trying to come up with a more accurate ways of
testing,
especially during different stages.
Because the hypothesis is,
uh,
the theories that when,
during heavy rem sleep and,
um,
during periods of extreme stress when your body believes that it's going to die,
like if you're under extreme physical trauma,
like people that have had extreme physical trauma,
you know,
and they have that go to the light moment.
The,
the idea is that that's a dimethyltryptamine rush and that the reason why they
have these intense after life experiences.
And they came,
I came back and it was amazing.
I got to see my mother and I went to this place and God was there.
You can get there.
If you take psychedelic drugs,
you can get there right now as a healthy person can have almost the exact same
type of experience with a psychedelic drugs.
And it's just a crazy psychedelic drug.
Cause your own brain makes dimethyltryptamine,
um,
that you produced in the pineal gland crosses over the blood brain barrier and
starts affecting things like in your brain.
Does it,
is it binding to different receptors and stuff in your brain?
It wouldn't be a question for someone far smarter than me,
but,
but the,
the drug,
uh,
Iowasca I'm sure you've heard of that.
I've heard of dimethyltryptamine as well and I just am not a well versed in the
whole field.
Well,
it's just a crazy drug because it's the most potent psychedelic drug known to
man and it's the one produced by your own brain.
So it's,
it's really weird.
Is it pretty loose?
Like is,
is it like from Melatonin or is it completely different?
Completely different.
But it's very similar to Melatonin in its chemical structure.
It's,
it's related.
Like they're close.
It's weird.
I mean,
because Melatonin regulates the sleep wake cycle and the circadian rhythm.
So,
you know,
I'm just,
I'm wondering if it's very similar in structure to Melatonin.
Would it have any role in that as well,
Katie and rhythm?
I think they're all connected.
I mean they tried to like,
okay,
this is,
um,
the,
when you look at,
um,
any of the,
any of the studies that they've done on a,
on the human mind and,
uh,
the studies that they've done connecting various hormones and,
and,
uh,
things like,
well,
whether it's a diamond field trip to mean or Melatonin or Tryptofan,
I think it's probably pretty safe to say that it's kind of,
I mean,
we know a lot about that stuff or they know a lot about that stuff,
but they're not entirely certain about all the different effects that these
regulating hormones have on the brain.
Is that safe to say?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
It's very complex.
I think they're probably the most ignorant about dimethyltryptamine because if,
because it's,
you know,
a lot,
it's been thought of as a recreational drug for a long time so people aren't
studying as much probably,
well the only guy that I know that's had grants to study it and has been allowed
to study it by the,
what was it,
the food and drug administration or who regulates,
uh,
who,
I guess it would be the FDA that would regulate that.
Now in terms of like the recreational drugs,
I,
you know,
I don't know.
I think it's the FDA because it diamond field trip to me is a really weird one
because although it's illegal,
it's in so many different things,
it's impossible to get the sources illegal because dimethyltryptamine is in like
a thousand different plants and it's in grass.
I mean,
you could get graph,
you could literally get flares grasp.
Um,
you just go mow a lawn,
the flares grass lawn,
take the bag of that shit,
bring it to a lab somewhere and you got DMT and you have a schedule one drug and
it's just kind of Anna's cat.
Well,
she passed away recently.
She was,
he liked to go out side and Tewa she heard some grass like,
I mean it was like,
and she would,
she would get real crazy about it too.
It was like a,
you know,
like you want to see something really crazy.
You want to see a Jaguar trip out,
pull that video of a Jaguar tripping out on DMT Jaguars in the Amazon.
Find these DMT rich plants and the chew them and eat them and have psychedelic
experiences.
And they have a different,
apparently they have a different way of processing things in their stomachs than
we do because they're primarily carnivores so they don't have the same gut
enzymes and things like,
here's the,
here's the Jaguar up little place for you.
Then we'll discuss it.
But it's so crazy because this Jaguar like they do it actively.
It's like something they do on a regular basis and they've observed that many
times.
They'll eat these grasses and these plants rather.
And then they just tripped it balls up.
Raw Lodge cards.
Jackie was,
he leaves when regurgitated,
they cleanse the digestive system.
Uh,
like cat nip some plants in juice that effects,
uh huh.
This Jaguar is,
first of all,
that's one of the communist rain forest vines.
It seems to cause playful kittenish behavior.
Yeah.
But could something deeper be happening
that cat is seeing all kinds of shit right now.
They're the king of the jungle.
I mean the Jaguars in the real jungles.
People in a hallucinogenic ritual.
Yeah.
The brain's fascinating.
I mean it's,
biology itself is pretty,
pretty complicated.
And you'll look at this Jaguar,
his eyes are dilated.
This is the same exact plant that people use,
an Iowaska rituals.
So this jaguars eating it and he's lying on his back.
The Jaguar also like an eight senses when he taught.
It's pretty fascinating stuff.
Like so much of weird nature.
There is still so much to know.
The,
um,
the,
the human gut produces monoamine oxidase,
which makes dimethyltryptamine uh,
it doesn't,
it kills it in the gut so that if you consume grass that has DMT in it,
you're,
you don't have a psychedelic trip.
But I don't know if a cat has the same gut enzyme.
Yeah.
I don't,
I'm not sure.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
your gut,
your gut has a lot.
I mean it's making neurotransmitters or you know it's,
there's,
there's neurons down there doing stuff and there's a connection between the
brain and the gut as well.
But this is so far,
the whole thing about the human mind is so fascinating where someone like you
who is just sort of putting together all these different things that you found
in,
in different books and,
and you go,
well hey look,
this combination of things is going on in the vitamin D and d,
vitamin D depletion and then here we have this issue with autism and autism has
to do with inflammation.
The Gut.
Yeah.
I put together a lot of stuff and I explained the male dominance and all this
and a really,
my goal was,
look,
maybe I'm right on,
you know,
maybe I'm wrong on some of these things,
but you know,
I'm definitely right about some,
some of these things here.
I'm interjecting it,
interjecting it into the,
you know,
the world,
the scientific world for all you people that actually do research on autism and
do research on Serotonin and all this.
Because I don't,
I mean,
that's not what I do.
Um,
and,
and I think that that's,
it's,
it's good to have theoretical papers like that sometimes where it's like you get
someone who can make all these connections where there's tons of stuff buried in
the literature.
And I had a mechanism,
I had a specific mechanism that explained it and,
uh,
you kind of just say here now if you think,
if you think it's an interesting followup on it.
And actually we started collaborating with a group that does do research on one
of these,
you know,
uh,
looks at Serotonin and does vitamin D research.
And they were just jumping out of their chairs there,
were so excited.
And so now they're doing experiments and if I have already found positive data,
which is really nice and reinforcing,
but,
so that's,
you know,
that was,
that was my goal is chuck kind of just make these connections,
big picture,
you know,
find a mechanism,
finding a mechanism by which vitamin deregulated Saratonin was amazing.
And,
uh,
putting it out in literature,
I mean,
but the whole vitamin D thing,
vitamin D three is important.
And I think it's something that most people are,
70% of the population is not getting an adequate,
you know,
70% 70.
Yeah.
Actually,
um,
we have someone reach out to me on Twitter after,
after the last podcast and artist and he was like,
look,
I really like what you're doing and you know,
I've been wanting to make a cool infographic just basically summarizing
everything I ever talk about with vitamin D.
It's like all in one graphic and he did it for me and if you want to pull it up,
it's on found my fitness.com forward slash vitamin D.
Hi.
No Vitamin Hyphen d and it's a fricking awesome infographic where this guy,
this guy's name,
oh,
his name's Jason,
right?
Jason.
Jason,
right?
Yeah.
So uh,
he made this infographic where it's like,
basically I talk about how vitamin D regulates a thousand different genes in the
body.
Yeah.
Here it is.
So it starts off here.
It's got this guy with all these like chromosomes and in with Tila mirrors
because vitamin D is important for telomere length.
Who I want to talk about that too.
Oh,
totally.
And then if you scroll down,
it's like,
look,
he's showing,
oh,
70% of the US population does not have adequate levels.
I thought that was really cool.
The graph to see 10 people.
Yeah,
exactly.
Right.
And then it goes on it.
And this is like you're a tag cloud where it's like all the things that go wrong
when you don't have enough vitamin D.
He's incredible.
Awesome.
So,
and it's like learning impairments,
you know,
reduce Saratonin,
increase cancer risk,
all I mean by nine over a thousand different genes in the body.
It's a need.
Scroll down more.
And it shows a teal and rare because it actually DNA,
DNA repair enzymes are regulated by vitamin D as well.
So if you're not getting enough vitamin D,
You're going to have,
you can see that break in your DNA.
You're going to get damage to DNA.
And then as you keep going,
it shows you,
oh,
all the factors that regulate your vitamin D,
like how sunscreen blocks UVB.
So you can't make it with Sunscreen,
a Melanin,
which is an adaptation to prevent UVB rays from burning.
You actually also blocks your ability to make vitamin D and body fat regulates
it.
So all these different body fat regulation regulates the bioavailability of it.
So it has to be released into the bloodstream to get converted into active
hormone age.
Age regulates it.
A 70 year old makes,
um,
four times less vitamin D from their skin.
Then there are former 20 year old self,
all these things living in the northern latitudes and other thing people at live
in like,
I think it says a above 37 degrees north with the exception of the summer.
They cannot make any vitamin D from the sun.
Wow.
So the solution is vitamin D supplement and uh,
we,
you know,
this is just a really awesome way to put all this great information.
Uh,
you know,
show it with graphics,
people like that.
And it's hard,
easier for people to understand and it,
and I go into,
you know,
what your level should be and all that,
but I was really stoked because I,
I've been wanting to do this for a really long time and I have no artistic
capabilities.
So,
no,
that's so cool.
Someone just reaching out to me and,
and wanting to help was like,
err,
you know,
it was really cool.
So,
um,
where is it on your website if you're looking for it?
I think if you sign up for my newsletter,
I think it's,
yeah.
Yeah.
I think that's,
that's how your website's getting crushed right now.
It's really hard to even get to is it took me five chances to get to it.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's not so,
so yeah,
that,
that's the,
uh,
the cool,
the vitamin D.
That's very cool.
Yeah,
totally.
The telomere mere length
thing.
The reason why I wanted to get to that is because I had emailed you about this
supplement that I had read about called t a 65.
And I had read about it because my friend Bobby,
uh,
he,
emailed me about it and,
uh,
his dad was taken.
That's bad.
Bobby for folks on the message board,
B A,
his damn is taking in.
His Dad started experiencing,
um,
vision improvement and I was like,
that,
that's fucking crazy.
And so like what does this ta 65 stuff.
So I go on to Google and I Google ta 65 and there's a whole knees,
well,
crazy claims and Ilana people are selling it and you know,
there's a lawsuit against it because there was a guy who was working for the
company,
a former executive who uh,
who is suing them because he says that it might have caused him to it to get
cancer.
And I mean,
the idea is what they're saying.
This is a,
you know,
the company that sells it.
Um,
this is the correlation between cellular aging and telomere length is rooted in
solid research.
Telomeres become shorter every time a cell divides and when they are lost,
cells can no longer reproduce the enzyme telomeres tell him arrays.
How'd he say it?
Telomerase.
Telomerase,
telomerase can lengthen telomeres possibly slowing or reversing degenerative
diseases.
In one study,
mice genetically engineered to lack functional telemere rays tell marines
telomerase
Dulac functional to telomerase showed brain degeneration and shrunk and testes.
But those effects
were reversed when the enzyme was reactivated in such findings have sparked a
lot of hype and encourage a cottage industry of companies that assess a person's
biological age on the basis of their telomere length.
But ta sciences has taken the buzz further and they sell a pill called ta 65,
which it says can shorten,
couldn't lengthen,
excuse me.
Short telomeres.
Yes.
All right.
No tilimeers yes,
but let me,
let me explain.
This is
so complicated,
but I think I can,
I think I can shed some light.
Okay,
so this is all right.
You know,
Tila Mirrors,
she,
you know,
every cell in your body has 46 chromosomes with the exception of your,
Gametes,
which I have 23.
But um,
these chromosomes have your DNA,
okay?
They're wound up with these histone proteins and that's where your DNA is.
And at the end of these chromosomes are your telomeres.
The problem is is that these tilimeers have a funny structure where their DNA,
they have,
it's a,
it's a repeat of t,
t a,
g,
G,
G and there's like this structural defect in your and the DNA of the teal where
there's a big overhang and like one of your strands of DNA is longer than the
other one.
And so when your cell,
when the cell divides and it's got,
it's got a copy,
its entire genome with all those 46 chromosomes to make a new cell with all that
same DNA,
there's a,
there's a little gap there at the end cause it's like,
oh my God,
I don't have anything here.
What do I,
how do I make the new DNA?
And so what happens is the next cell then has a little bit shorter telomere
because there was that little gap that didn't get filled.
And this is happening so successfully over multiple generations year after year,
after year after year.
Each time it gets a little shorter.
Each time he gets a little shorter and that becomes a problem because these
telomeres are actually protecting your DNA from damage.
You know,
oxidative damage from,
from unwinding and also from your chrome,
your chromosomes.
When your cell divides a year,
they protect our chromosomes from fusing together and like getting all these
funny abnormal translocations,
which lead to cancer and other problems.
So you don't want that to happen.
And the problem is,
is that you,
most of ourselves,
with the exception of our stem cells and our lymphocytes don't express this
enzyme called telomerase,
which is able to actually rebuild the telomeres.
It's actually able to rebuild the end where that,
that telomere little gap where we can't make it.
So it's really cool.
It's like,
well,
here's this great enzyme that can rebuild it,
but why is it only in our stem cells and why isn't it an all of ourselves?
Uh,
the,
the gene is there,
but it's just not activated.
It's,
you know,
silenced.
And the,
a answer for that as well.
If you're,
if you express too much telomerase and all these other cells,
um,
what happens is you can make a cell and mortal and cancer cells have actually
developed.
They're so smart.
Cancer cells are like the smartest thing ever.
Um,
they've developed this,
this capability to reactivate that enzyme to become immortal.
Um,
but the really ironic thing is,
is that it's the critically short telomeres when you're short,
when your telomeres get to a really,
really,
really short stage,
they go into this crisis where it's like,
oh my God,
what do I do?
What do I do?
You know?
And they either die or they,
you know,
go into this senescence state where they don't divide or they somehow can
reactivate this telomerase.
And at that point,
if they reactivate this telomerase,
you can,
if you,
if this is a damaged cell that already has mutations and stuff,
you're like,
boom,
okay,
we're going to,
we're going to keep you going now.
So it's kind of paradoxical that the short telomere length is what actually can
reactivate the telomerase to make,
make it become immortal and make cancer.
Yeah.
Well,
if you already have mutation,
yeah.
If it's already like an abnormal cell because you've already gotten damaged and
stuff to it.
Yes,
exactly.
She can take a precancerous cell and say,
here,
keep going.
Grow more.
So,
um,
so this is a,
the telomerase is in stem cells because your stem cells aren't dividing that
much.
So usually just sitting around waiting to,
they have to come out and divide and make more of a certain cell type and then
they go back into just waiting around.
So they're not constantly,
you know,
dividing meaning they're not constantly get at risk for more damage.
And I can explain that later.
But anyway,
so the,
the telomerase and the mice,
this is kind of cool.
So you talked about these telomerase deficient mice.
Well,
mice actually,
it's really weird.
They express telomerase and all their cells,
their team members don't get shorter and yet they only lived two years on
average.
And so in order to try to understand the biological mechanisms by which,
and telomere shortening what that,
what those effects are,
you have to genetically engineer them to not express that telomerase.
And what happens is over multiple generations,
it takes like three,
three or four.
When you get to generation for,
you know,
then you start to see progeria types of effects where now these mice they're
born to is a fourth generation of not having this enzyme.
It takes like that long to actually get the telomeres to it really short level
where it starts to have perjury effects and they start to prematurely age their
tissue,
start to,
you know,
break down and they have all these sorts of aging effects.
Um,
and so what they've shown is they can reactivate telomerase at that point after
four generations and it reverses those biological effects.
So the tissues become younger.
This stem cells,
you know,
our,
active and making replenishing populations like they're supposed to.
So it's kind of cool.
It's like here you have this pro aging mouse,
you reactivate the enzyme and it literally reversed the aging in these mice
would have a possible benefit to children that have progeria.
So,
um,
the,
it depends on what type of progeria.
There's,
there's certain ones like there's Werner Syndrome,
which if you,
um,
pull out,
if you just Google Warner Syndrome and image it.
W E r n e R.
Warner.
That's a,
a disease that's,
um,
info involves,
you know,
short telomeres.
So you're basically,
you're,
you can't rebuild your telomeres and the,
it's excessive to telomere shortening.
And what happens is,
yeah,
if you click on the,
the one with the two with pictures of the women,
um,
by the time they reach puberty,
like 15,
uh,
no,
not that one.
The,
there was,
if you go back,
there's the,
yeah,
the,
it's like Filipino woman there I think left.
Yeah.
There we go.
Left hand corner.
Perfect.
Yes.
So like she ages normally up until the age of about 15,
and then after 15,
she's 40 years old in that right,
right hand picture.
Wow.
40.
I mean,
she looks like she's like right or 90.
Yeah,
she looks pretty old.
So,
um,
in that,
in that case,
it'd be interesting to see if having telomerase could help rebuild the telomers.
But like I said,
because of the potential danger of allowing a precancerous cell to become
immortal,
I think there's been a lot of,
there's a lot of people are careful about that.
And that's why it's not like on the market right now where you're just,
people are selling it.
This is the thing,
this a ta 65 stuff and this is the,
uh,
the lawsuit is that this guy who worked for them,
is saying that he got cancer.
So the thing with reactivating telomerase is if you are,
if you generally are healthy,
you don't have a lot of your c reactive proteins low,
you're not,
you don't have a lot of inflammation,
a lot of damaged cells,
then a lot of precancer cells,
your immune system is getting rid of them.
You know,
reactivating telomerase in a normal cell is not really a bad thing.
It's not going to make it a cancer cell.
It's going to make it a mortal.
It's going to help you know it not have critically short Tila mirrors.
The problem is Rianna debating it in a cell that has a bunch of damage in it.
And so to me,
you know,
measuring,
looking,
looking at how much damages in your cell.
Like we can do that.
I do that right now in people.
I take the blood cells and I look at DNA damage,
check it out.
Yeah.
You have to come,
you can't,
uh,
you'd have to come down to the bay and the bay area and sign a consent form.
That's it.
Just like you signed a consent form when you a do a podcast.
Uh,
yeah.
Kind of,
kind of like that,
just to be in part of my trial.
So,
so like what,
what do you do?
So what I do is I,
I take blood,
well I get an MD to take it from for me.
And so they draw the blood and then I take the blood and I sent her a few shit
through this gradient where I can then isolate just the peripheral blood
mononuclear cells,
which are like mostly B and t lymphocytes that's in some monocytes.
So I don't have any red blood cells or platelets or any of those neutrophils.
I don't want,
those are Mac macrophages or things like that.
So,
and I take those,
those peripheral blood mononuclear cells and I look at the amount of double
stranded breaks in the DNA.
So I can actually measure that.
I can quantify that.
And I'm not only do I look at those double stranded breaks in the DNA,
so the double stranded breaks,
um,
I think we talked about this a little bit last time.
So just normal living,
it's just,
it's so it's a like here's aging for you in a nutshell.
Just normal age,
living your metabolism,
your mitochondria are generating,
generating oxygen,
rattled radicals,
which you know,
gets your DNA and you get enough of these oxygen radicals.
It caused the strand break and then you get them in parallel.
You have to strand breaks,
UV radiation does the same thing,
but let's just forget about all the outside stuff.
Like forget about carcinogens,
UV,
smoking,
all that.
Just normal.
You know,
living does this and this happens every single day,
you know,
and so your,
your body has to repair that damage.
And I talked about those enzymes that are magnesium,
magnesium dependent and how magnesium is important for DNA repair enzymes.
And 45% of the population doesn't have enough of that.
Well,
I'm looking at people that are obese and those people usually don't have a
really good diet and they're most often magnesium deficient.
Well,
I don't want to say deficient cause it's not like a clinical acute deficiency.
It's like they're inadequate.
Okay.
If inadequate levels of magnesium,
they're not taking enough magnesium,
which is 400 or so milligrams today.
They,
so I look at their DNA,
their strand breaks and then I have this because I think that they're not
getting enough magnesium.
I don't,
I'm not actually measuring their magnesium.
Someone else,
um,
that I work with can do that.
But I haven't,
we haven't,
I haven't found it necessary to do that yet.
Um,
then what I'm doing is I'm a Mac,
I'm measuring the capacity of their,
that their body has to repair a known amount of damage that I induce.
So I look at their baseline damage sandwich,
how much damage is there,
and then I induced damage with an radiator.
And then I measure over time the ability of their own enzymes to repair that
damage.
And what I'm finding is that if I look at someone who's lean or obese based on
BMI,
then I'm seeing there's differences.
I'm seeing that people with that are obese have a BMI of 30 or so.
They have a lot more of this damage in their blood cells.
And not only do they have a lot more of this damage,
their capacity to repair this damage is impaired.
So,
and it makes sense to me.
You know,
you're,
you're looking at,
you're talking about people that are eating poor diets.
They're,
they're eating very macro nutrient rich diet diets.
You know,
they're eating a lot of processed foods and junk food and they're not getting
their micronutrients there.
Essential vitamins,
zinc,
magnesium,
these are,
these are required for like 300 different enzymes to work in the body.
And so I'm measuring one of those.
And that's DNA repair,
which is important to prevent cancer.
Um,
so anyways,
what were we talking?
We were talking.
That's right.
So I went on this whole,
so that's agent,
that's part of aging in a nutshell.
And there's other points of it I can,
we can get back to later in the conversation.
But,
so ta 65 is,
um,
I was actually really impressed because I read a couple of the studies.
So ta 65 astragalus root,
some Chinese herb or something or it,
that's,
that's what,
uh,
that's what it's from.
I believe from,
from what I read.
And,
uh,
I think I'm saying it right,
the stragglers route.
So it has the capacity to activate telomerase.
Um,
and there's,
there's two different papers that were pretty good.
One paper was a clinical paper where they looked,
they gave people varying doses of ta 65 and I don't remember the exact doses,
but they did a dose response and they looked at a couple of things.
A,
they looked at the activation of that enzyme,
telomerase and B,
they looked at telomere length.
So they started the trial baseline measure,
telomere length and telomerase activity.
And then they gave people these ta 65 at various doses of it.
And what they found is that in a dose dependent manner,
the ta 65 increased a telomerase activity.
Um,
and not only did it increase tall telomerase activity in the very high doses,
in a,
in a subset of people,
it actually increased the length of their telomere over baseline.
I've never seen this before usually.
So usually you're,
when you're doing a lot of other things affecting them or length vitamin DS,
one,
one of them,
vitamin D the Way Vitamin D effects telomere length is totally different than
the way ta 65 to,
because vitamin D is preventing DNA damage,
inflammation and things that accelerate telomere shortening.
Ta 65 is literally rebuilding the end of your telomeres.
So it's possible to actually start and end up with a longer telomere as opposed
to,
you know,
other nutritional factors that regulate just delaying the attrition of it.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
So that over baseline they had like a 40%,
I believe from reading that paper awhile ago,
a 40% increase in telomere length.
That's incredible.
It was incredible.
It's incredible.
So then I went and read the other study,
which was the,
the mouse study.
Um,
and actually the woman,
the lead investigator on,
I'm very familiar with her work.
I was really close to doing a postdoc in telomere and the two of them were lab.
Cause I've,
I've been very interested in tilimeers for quite some time.
Um,
so I had been familiar with herder her papers,
like her publications.
And I was like,
when I saw that she was,
it was from her lab,
I was like,
oh it's,
I know I'm familiar with her work.
You know,
she's pretty good.
I'm pretty thorough.
And so her paper,
what she did was she took that same mouse model that I was talking about where
they over successive generations,
they knock out that telomerase enzyme and they over,
you know,
three or four or five generations and they start to get these mice that have
really short telomeres that are aging.
Their tissues are aging quicker.
And they gave those mice like third or fourth generation mice,
ta 65.
And what they found was that giving those minds to ta 65 was able to rejuvenate
their tissue.
You know,
that she,
she started to look younger are very similar to telomerase reactivation,
not as robust,
which isn't surprising.
I mean,
you're talking about reactivating the entire enzyme versus something that's
just,
you know,
able to activate it.
But they,
the mice didn't get cancer.
Um,
they,
they didn't get any types of cancer.
So,
but like I said,
now,
if you were to take,
if you were to take a mouse model,
knock out their telomerase enzyme,
inoculate them with cancer cells,
so give them cancer cells and then react and then giving them the ta 65,
it'd be,
they're probably going to do that experiment.
I mean,
that's the,
that's the logical thing to do next,
just to make sure,
um,
to,
to really prove that it's,
it's,
it's pretty safe.
Um,
so bottom line is,
I was impressed with ta 65.
Um,
actually,
surprisingly so.
I,
and you know,
personally,
I,
you know,
I think there's always that risk.
It's like,
well,
if you have a lot of precancerous cells,
there's no telling.
I,
you know,
I obviously,
if the,
if it was a big issue,
more people would be coming down with cancer.
I wonder how many people are taking this stuff.
I've only heard of a couple of people that I know they're taking it.
I've read some folks online and a message board that I go to that say they
started taking it,
but I don't know enough of it
about how many are,
I don't know how many people are taking it either.
Um,
that that would be my one concern though,
is that having a bunch of precancerous cells,
reactivating telomerase in those cells,
then pushing them,
giving them the fuel they need to then make more cancer cells.
That's a possibility.
People that own the company there with the guys,
it's a whole thing is really,
really odd.
I don't know exactly what happened because apparently there was like some sort
of a physical art,
the altercation with the guy who was suing them and they're suing him because
they're saying that they lost $2 million in sales because he said that he got
cancer,
which is,
and they're also saying that if he had cancer,
he had it before he started taking ta 65
how the fuck could you ever know that?
Right.
Well,
but that's the thing,
that's,
that's the thing right.
If you have cancer before taking it,
right.
I'm not saying this is going to happen.
I'm saying theoretically reactivating telomerase could push those cancer cells
to full blown precancerous cells to full blown blown cancer because now there's
immortalizing them and letting them survive and propagate and pull it right.
That here's the question.
Here's the big one.
Is there
a diet,
a thing that you can do?
The,
the word is always,
oh,
you need to have a,
you know,
a cancer cells can't grow in an alkaline environment,
but I've,
I've heard it,
that's horseshit to that,
this idea of alkalizing your blood and having a diet that makes your blood or
your body alkaline rich is horse shit.
I'm totally not familiar with any of that.
So never heard of that before.
I've heard of people wanting to alkaline their blood.
I know why.
I never
really followed up on it and I certainly haven't heard about the cancer
connection to it.
So that's new to me.
Um,
I've definitely heard of other things people are trying to do.
Well,
you can go alkaline cancer.
And one of the first things that pops up is myth,
the acid alkaline myth.
Um,
if what I've read the w that's counteracting this is that if you did alter the
alkaline of your body,
like the,
the variables are so small that if you've,
if you alter it in,
in,
in any sort of a shocking way,
your body just is fucked.
Like it's,
it's not good.
Right?
No,
it's true.
I mean,
I think with the exception of,
of,
of the gut where you're trying to actually make a little more,
you want,
you want these different gut bacteria to make more acidic,
you know,
to be more acidic and make more,
acidic type of environment to get rid of the bad bacteria,
which can't grow in that type of environment.
Um,
but all the other stuff,
I think,
yeah,
there's,
there's slight changes and Ph and I mean,
you're,
you're talking about activating the immune systems sensitive to this sort of
stuff.
I mean,
it's like all of a sudden you start activating your neutrophils and you know,
they don't know why they're activated,
but when they're activated it's just like fire,
fire,
fire on their fire for firing all kinds of crap cytokines which are making,
you know,
reactive nitrogen species which are damaging your DNA and your lipids and your
proteins.
So it's like,
you know,
there's,
there's things like that going on.
You don't,
you know.
Yeah.
Anyways,
this,
this critique of it was saying that foods don't influence the blood Ph and they
were saying,
this is,
I'll just read what it says here on this guy's website,
proponents of the alkaline diet,
I've put forth a few different theories about how acidic diet harms our health.
The most ridiculous claim,
it more ridiculous claim is that we can change the Ph of our blood by changing
the foods we eat and that the acidic blood causes disease while alkaline blood
prevents it.
This is not true.
The body type is all reference to a,
I'll give the guy's website.
It's a Chris Kresser,
C H R I S K r e s.
S.
E R.
Dot Com.
Um,
um,
uh,
this is not true.
The body tightly regulates the Ph of our blood and extra cellular fluid and we
cannot influence our blood ph by changing our diet with references,
a high doses of sodium bicarbonate contemporarily increased blood ph,
but not without causing uncomfortable GI syndromes,
symptoms rather.
And there are certainly circumstances in which blood is more acidic than it
should be.
And this does have serious health consequences.
However,
this state of acidosis is caused by pathological conditions such as chronic
renal in SIF insufficiency,
not by whether or not you choose to eat a salad or a burger.
In other words,
regardless of what you eat or what your urine Ph is,
you can be pretty confident that your blood ph is hovering around a comfortable
7.4.
Yeah,
I do all that.
You know,
all you need to make your body alkaline in cancer can't exist in an alkaline
environment.
Horseshit,
right?
I,
you know,
I just don't know enough about that,
that stuff.
Um,
honestly to say definitively if it's,
you know,
I really don't,
I know that things in vitro,
you know,
when you're looking at cancer,
if you're talking about growing cancer cells in a dish and changing that,
you know,
environment,
environment is one thing,
but I don't know.
Yeah.
I don't know either.
That's the problem.
God Damn it.
Well,
I mean,
it's something,
you know,
if you're,
if you want to email me,
I'll look into it.
Yeah,
I will.
Yeah.
It's just a matter of me not having dug into something like that.
But that's like,
it's one of those things,
it just gets repeated
over and over again.
And by the way,
it's,
this is apparently this,
this,
uh,
mythbusting is,
there's a bunch of different websites that say that it's horse shit.
So,
and a bunch of different doctors with references about the,
um,
this,
this whole alkaline thing.
Here's the cancer myth number one,
that cancer doesn't feed on sugar.
Almost every new patient.
It says,
ask me about this,
uh,
theories prevalent on the Internet that sugar will influence blood sugar levels,
feed cancer,
and cause it to spread.
The truth is you can't really control blood sugar by what you eat.
The body's complex system processes what we eat and manages to keep blood sugar
level stable.
Whether that's,
is that true?
That doesn't make sense.
Well,
I mean you're obviously when you're eating sugar or you're inducing an insulin
response,
which then you take the sugar up into yourselves.
So that regulates the blood sugar levels.
Unless that doesn't,
unless you're type two diabetic or something that's not working,
then you know,
then you can't regulate your blood sugar levels normally.
And that's not good.
It's saying
ception to this of course is people with diabetes who don't have the proper
insulin regulating systems.
But if you apply the theory that sugar can affect your insulin levels and feed
cancer,
diabetics with cancer would all be dying of their cancer.
What,
what?
Yeah,
exactly.
What kind of fucking quotas that Dr Holen,
who are you fucking Weirdo that doesn't make any sense.
He's an oncologist to [inaudible]
specializes in gastrointestinal and esophageal esophageal Sapa.
Jayleeya esophageal cancers says at worst,
a,
these myths may lead vulnerable cancer patients to try untested treatments or
procedures.
Hmm.
You know,
the thing is,
is that cancer cells do acquire this capability to become glycolytic.
Where there,
instead of using glucose to convert into pirate bay and go into the Mitochondria
and use this whole mitochondrial metabolism,
oxidative phosphorylation to generate energy,
they become,
they use this whole pathway that's called glycolysis,
which is a,
it's a much shorter pathway and they,
they're using it to,
to generate,
you know,
that's how they're using to generate the energy.
So I think that probably plays a role in people coming up with all these
different theories and things that manipulating the glucose and all that.
What,
what it can do.
I know that,
you know,
I did a lot of work manipulating cancer nutrients in cancer cells and Grad
School and um,
you know,
getting,
if I,
if I had this is in vitro,
first of all,
if I do it in vitro,
I take,
if I take a cancer cell and I take away their glucose,
but they still have all these glutamine,
they have,
you know,
these other amino acids and that they were fine.
They grow slower,
but they wouldn't die if I took away their glutamine,
they would die within like 24 hours.
And it's,
you know,
for me to think about cancer cells,
well not only do they need energy,
ATP,
they need nitrogen source to make new nucleotides for new DNA.
And also new amino acids.
They need molecules like to build lipids for lipid or you know,
your lipid membrane.
So it,
it,
there's a lot of,
you know,
just,
just taking away the glucose is one thing.
But there's a lot of other,
you know,
macromolecules that are really required for cancer proliferation that are also
important.
So I,
you know,
taking some,
it's taking some of the stuff that we're learning in science and immediately
applying it I think in some cases can be a little dangerous.
Um,
you know,
just because we don't exactly understand how all these mechanisms are working
together.
So I'm a little cautious about taking some something that we're learning in
science and immediately applying it to yourself,
especially if you have cancer.
It's so fascinating.
I mean,
if you think about like the last time I was here,
I was talking about the folic acid.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
and how that's,
that's a perfect example where folic acid is,
is great for you if you don't have cancer because you can build new DNA.
But if you have cancer,
taking a lot of it is not great for you because you build new DNA and that's
what cancer cells are doing when they're dividing.
So,
you know,
that's,
and there's another example of that with another micronutrient by one of the
vitamin E's.
So,
uh,
actually this would be a transition into,
to some of the office and stuff cause he was talking about that specifically.
Oh,
the uh,
the doctor,
that stuff that I sent you.
Yeah,
this is,
um,
so w,
w.
W we definitely get into that and I would love to in a moment,
so just to let everybody know,
it's,
it seems,
you know,
if you're not interested in doing any of the research,
it seems that almost everyone who's done any research on this alkaline diet
thing says it's horseshit.
But they do say that these foods that they're suggesting that you eat to keep an
alkaline rich diet are very healthy for you.
So in that sense,
it's good for you because it's going to provide your body with the nutrients
that it needs.
A,
especially if you're nutrient deficient,
you're much more likely to be unhealthy.
If you're much more likely to be unhealthy,
your immune system's going to have a harder time dealing with any host of
different diseases.
But that this alkaline thing of your body,
your body basically hovers between 7.3 and 7.45.
Your stomach is very acidic with a Ph of 3.5 or below.
So it can break down food and your urine changes depending on what you eat and
that's how your body keeps the level and your body steady.
But that,
this idea that you're going to regulate the alkaline of your body with food and
that you're gonna keep your body in an alkaline state show.
Well,
there's a lot of low sort of like myths going on.
In fact,
recently I think I saw on your Twitter you posted something,
I don't know,
a couple of days ago about Kale and uh,
yeah,
it's really,
it's really kind of,
it's,
it's Kinda there,
these people are doing more harm in the sentence and in some cases,
uh,
so,
you know,
Kale,
Kale and the cruciferous family like Broccoli,
cabbage,
Brussel sprouts,
these things.
Um,
they have something in them called Glu Glucose and Oles.
Okay.
And Glucose and all aids can get,
could they get cleaved by an enzyme called myrosinase,
which is in the plant and it forms something called isothiocyanates in
isothiocyanates are very,
um,
they've been shown to be very potent anticancer agents.
So they activate the,
it's actually a part of that for me since I was talking about,
because these are generated in the plant as a natural defense mechanisms.
It's one of their natural defense mechanism against bugs.
It's like a natural pesticide in innocence.
They produce it to keep bugs away.
Isothiocyanates are for us,
activate our variety of different genes that are involved in stress resistance,
including tumor suppressor genes,
which actually kill tumor cells.
And so,
and they've shown this,
they've shown this,
you know quite a few times that if you,
if you give mice like you know my SAP cancer isothiocyanates they will kill the
cancer cells and the whole isothiocyanates thing also compete competitively
binds to,
I had a the iodine transporter in the thyroid.
So here comes this whole,
Oh my God,
you can't eat kale because,
or cruciferous because it will screw up your thyroid and calls hyperthyroidism.
Right.
So the thing is though is these isothiocyanates they could,
they appear to competitively bind to the same transporter that iodine does to
get into the thyroid.
Now,
I was looking for the paper where they showed that and it's like 1948 because
what I wanted to see was a dose dependent manner of giving them,
you know,
these isothiocyanates or Kale and show how much of it,
competes it with iodine.
How much do you know doesn't,
well,
I couldn't get access to that paper.
But what I did find is that when you give these mice isothiocyanates a lot of
them that kills cancer cells,
but it doesn't cause any thyroid problems,
which leads me to believe is that the Isis Ioc nights probably very,
very,
very small degree of a competitive inhibition of getting iodine into your
thyroid,
which if you don't,
if you aren't low,
and I'd on wouldn't be a problem because you're not,
you know.
So if it's just very small amount of it,
competing with it to get it to get iodine into the thyroid is not going to be a
problem unless you're really,
really deficient in iodine and then any small amount and you need,
so in my opinion,
and for me,
uh,
I,
so I love getting isothiocyanates from,
from these cruciferous.
And by the way,
the enzyme myrosinase that converts that the glucose and all eights into isis
thiocyanate is heat sensitive.
Um,
so if you heat it,
it will generally inactivate it and not completely,
but it doesn't activate it for the most part.
And so you're not getting as many of those isothiocyanates,
which is probably why people started to say,
oh,
boil your,
boil your Kale.
Or,
um,
I personally want the isothiocyanates because the data is so strong showing that
these things kill cancer cells.
I mean,
it's a,
it's a well known fact that these things sold.
This idea that raw kale or any of these Rah Rah.
There's another one,
there's Brussel sprouts,
but then there's another,
so that's that story about the height of that.
Those are bad for you.
Seems as bullshit.
Well,
yeah,
that's what I'm just,
I mean,
to me it,
you know,
hormesis okay.
It depends on what you're defining as bad for you are saying for me since it's
activating a bunch of genes that are tumor suppressor genes that kill cancer
cells.
I mean it's good for you,
these isothiocyanates or good,
good for you if you don't,
if you're not like completely deficient in iodine,
which most people aren't.
I mean I think that there's some problem with women in their twenties or forties
but supplemented iodine while you were taking these ISO thiocyanate
sinaits they're very,
I've been talking about these for years.
Like how awesome they,
I want them.
Like I want them in my bottom.
I want my eyes to that.
You're saying it so I'm telling you.
I did.
I did,
but
so,
um,
cause they're fucking awesome.
I get,
it kind of irks me because I'm like,
I see all this stuff and it's like,
no,
don't not,
you know,
there's still not eat your raw kale because you,
you want to get things like ice.
Who thought he was saying there's,
there's chemicals in these plants that are,
yes,
they're,
you know,
they're slightly toxic,
but they're inducing stress response mechanisms in our body that are good for
us.
They're fighting off all that,
all the bad stuff that we're making in our body.
Everything,
you know,
it's,
it's a good thing.
Precancerous cells are always happening.
You want tumor suppressor genes are genes that when there's something's wrong,
like you have,
you get that DNA damage.
I was talking about something happens where a mutation happens in a cell,
it senses it,
you know,
and it activates this whole response pathway where it's like dye and it kills
the cell.
So having something that activates those pathways in your body,
like isothiocyanates is a good thing.
It's,
you know,
and,
and personally I want more of them.
So all this stuff about this poorly researched bad conclusions.
Um,
so the thing is,
is when you look at the,
when you look in the literature,
um,
the,
if you're trying to look at the effects of Isis,
I sign it's on thyroid function.
There's not a whole huge literature on it.
Like I said,
I was looking for the experiment to prove to me.
I wanted to see how much competitive inhibition there was.
I think they're also called icy threes.
I see threes on the iodine transport and the thyroid.
I couldn't find it.
I'd say I'll review articles where they referred to it.
I looked to the reference,
go to the reference.
It's,
you know,
it's some other reviewer.
It's just there's no,
I want it to see the data.
And I had to dig,
dig until I got to 1948 where they did this competitive binding essay.
Um,
and then I found other papers talking about,
oh,
it's only an effect if you have low iodine.
Which made me think,
well,
I can't see the data.
But what I think makes sense is that only if it's such a low competitive
binding,
that's not,
you know,
it's not like if you eat this,
you're gonna not get iodine.
It's that if you already are at that point where you don't have it any little
bit,
you don't get,
makes a difference.
And I know,
and I know this because the mice,
the mouse models where they're not even looking at thyroid function and they're
looking at the effects of isothiocyanates and killing cancer cells,
those minds have no problems with becoming hyperthyroid and they're giving them
large doses.
So to me I'm like,
okay,
well that would have been a side effect.
They would've noticed,
you know,
so this is just completely theoretical and it doesn't work.
It doesn't work in practice.
What does this idea of getting hypothyroidism from?
I think if you have normal levels of iodine,
it's fine,
you're fine.
But if you're,
if you're like one of those people that is iodine deficient,
it may,
it may affect you because if it,
if,
if there's a small amount of it,
it does seem to compete with iodine transport,
but I think it's a very small competitive amount.
It's not a,
it's not like all the iodine,
it's not like all or nothing like all of it's getting in or not getting in.
I think it's a very small amount that doesn't get in.
But if you're not,
I,
if you're getting your iodine and you know,
it doesn't,
does that,
are you following?
Okay,
so that I hope people can follow that because I really,
there's so much of that horse these days.
There's so much contrarianism to so many people that want to debunk anything
that comes to thing.
And the other one is this oxalic acid.
I think you've kind of confuse the two.
But that was the one that Dave Asprey had talked about.
This.
Why does with Kale,
that's why I brought that up.
Kale.
Oh,
you had a boil Kale because of oxalic acid and during the war.
And let me tell you about that.
Um,
the oxalic acid,
I think there's a little bit in Kale,
but it's mostly in spinach,
oxalic acids,
and spent most the highest and the what people are saying on the Internet from
what I could see on this whole echo chamber thing that happens is that you need
to boil your spinach.
I guess it were in some people they're saying Kale.
Um,
because then you're going to inactivate this oxalic acid and now it's not going
to bind up minerals like magnesium,
calcium,
and they're saying that this is a problem if you don't do this,
because then you're going to get kidney stones.
Right?
So I was looking in the literature and I found a really cool experiment done by
this Japanese group where they took spinach,
raw spinach.
They boiled it,
they fried it,
they frizzled it.
I mean,
so they did,
you know,
various different temperatures and they,
then you make it into a powder to give to these mice that are magnesium
deficient.
They may put them on a magnesium deficient diet and they fed them either the raw
spinach,
the boil,
the Frizzell fried,
and they measured magnesium levels in their blood and their bone.
And they measured a calcium levels in their blood and bone and also in their
kidneys.
And what they found was that there was no difference in the magnesium and
calcium levels and the bone,
and also in the serum it,
whether or not you boiled Raul Fried,
whatever.
Frizzled uh,
however,
I'm sorry.
No,
it counts.
The calcium levels there were,
there was a difference from frying it or frizzling it,
but the raw and the boiling were the same.
And basically the conclusions were it doesn't effect absorption,
boiling or raw.
It's the same.
You're going to absorb the same amount of magnesium,
calcium,
there were magnesium and calcium in the kidney that did have him in the kidney
and it was a little bit higher concentrated versus the control,
but it wasn't causing,
you know,
kidney stones and things like that.
And there was no difference between boiling or not.
So if you're going to make the claim that,
you know,
having oxalic acid causes kidney stones and you need to boil it,
well maybe just there may be,
you need to say don't eat it,
but I don't think that's the case.
I don't think any of that's the case.
So having a look soggy,
I assume your diet from consuming it in raw form,
not bad.
I think it's it.
You'd have to consume a massive,
massive amount to cause something that would be like kidney stones.
What do you mean?
Like eating it every day all day?
No,
I mean like eating like,
like pounds,
pounds of it a day.
Yeah.
Every day.
So that's beautiful.
No,
I'm not here.
Here's the violence.
I have not convinced myself that I have to boil any of my spinach or kale before
I eat it raw.
I actually,
I actually put it in a smoothie every morning.
I make a smoothie with Kale,
raw kale,
raw spinach,
tomato,
carrot,
a avocado,
banana,
almond milk,
some berries,
and it's protein powder as well.
Anyways,
I haven't convinced myself that eating raw spinach in my smoothies every day,
you know,
and I put it,
I put a nice amount of it.
It's not pounds of it,
but,
um,
I haven't convinced myself that I'm doing any harm.
And this is obviously not just based on the way your body reacts,
but based on the research that you've done.
This is based on the,
the,
the little bit of reading that I've done on,
on those,
the isothiocyanates,
I'm definitely convinced that,
you know,
the,
the oxalic acid,
you know,
because it does bind minerals.
It's key later.
Um,
you know,
there may some cases where kidney,
can accumulate in the kidney.
But I think that from what,
from my reading that's really,
really large dose and I haven't convinced myself yet.
I'm not saying it's not possible,
but I haven't convinced myself that I need to worry about it.
So the idea that you're getting some sort of toxins from the vegetables because
the vegetables are trying to prevent predation,
right?
Nonsense.
No,
you aren't getting taught,
I mean nonsense that it's bad for you.
It's,
it's,
there's the,
they're activating for Musa,
so it is kind of toxic for you.
It kinda,
it's odd,
but it's an intubating stress response pathways that are ultimately,
it's like,
okay,
a little bit of bad for you activating a pathway really,
really good for you because now you're,
now you're turning on hundreds of genes that are involved in DNA repair,
that are involved in glutathione peroxidase,
getting rid of oxidation that are involved in,
uh,
you know,
making,
I mean,
making sure cancer cells die.
So to me,
you know,
you are getting a little bit of these toxins from these plants.
Absolutely.
But your body's counteracting of these toxins,
body's incredibly beneficial.
Your body is increased.
Yeah,
your body's pretty amazing.
Um,
and it is pretty beneficial,
the reaction to,
to some of these toxins.
So the point being that the incorrect correlation that people have made between
the very low toxicity between these,
these plants,
Kale,
Broccoli,
whatever,
and them being something that you should avoid consuming once you boil them.
That's just not,
yeah,
in mine,
in my opinion,
it doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense.
It doesn't make sense to me either.
So I think people can take something little and it becomes this sensational and
they're like,
oh,
it's very sensational because what's good for you is bad for you.
But if you do this little thing,
it becomes good for you again.
And I think that it's a good marketing tactic in some respects.
Do you know what I mean?
Where there is right is
one case,
there's a study,
um,
that you could find on a pub med site about excelling.
Yes.
Oxalate Nefro Pathi due to juicing.
And,
uh,
this patient with a Oxley induced acute renal failure that was attributable to a
consumption of oxalate rich fruit and vegetable juices obtained from juicing.
Uh,
we described the case and also review the clinical presentation of 65 patients
seen at the Mayo clinic in Rochester,
Minnesota from 1985 through 2010 with renal failure and biopsy proven renal
calcium oxalate crystals.
The cause of Reno Auc.
Solo sis was identified for all patients,
a single cause for 36 patients and at least two causes for 29 patients.
Three patients,
including our index patient had presumed diet induced oxalate and nef.
How do you say that word?
Nephropathy.
Yeah.
In the context of chronic kidney disease,
uh,
identification of calcium oxalate crystals in a kidney biopsy should prompt an
evaluation for causes
of renal oxaloacetate be blea.
Blea blea um,
so what does that mean?
I mean,
it sounds like there are these people,
how many of them were the,
that had the,
the,
from the juicing,
uh,
let's see,
65 patients from 1985 to 2010 this time.
And to have 65 patients.
And all of them actually single costs for 36 patients and at least two causes
for 29 patients too because they were all so,
yeah,
the single cause for the 36 patients they believe was juicing
is juicing.
Okay.
And the other one,
there's two causes.
Any of them,
So about three.
Yeah.
So to me it sounds like,
like I said,
you know,
you're,
there's always going to be cases where you can't,
you can't,
you can probably caused that to happen because it does bind and collate these
ions,
especially in juicing perhaps because you're taking us such a large quantity of
vegetables and breaking them down to a juice.
Would that make sense?
Get more oxalate?
Maybe so.
Maybe.
So.
Um,
cause like if you juice,
like,
think about like what are like a 16 ounce glass of juice,
how many vegetables have to go into the juicer to liquefy it down to,
I make smoothies for the most part,
I don't juice.
Um,
uh,
occasionally I buy a cold press juices,
but,
uh,
I'm most of what I do,
I'd just be like me,
I don't use either.
Um,
I've actually have not ever juiced.
I make smoothies as well.
But you know,
there I,
it sounds to me like there can be cases where you're getting a really
concentrated amount of this and you're doing it everyday.
Cause there's people out there that go extreme and no matter what they do,
they go like to the extreme.
And you know,
because you can,
you know,
the x,
the axilla catheter XL,
the anti and of it,
the oxalate can bind,
does bind to these metal ions at key lates than men.
You know,
it absolutely could accumulate in your kidney.
So,
but you would,
so the real key is the thing that we've always been taught to eat a balanced
diet.
I think most people are not going to that extreme.
Right.
And I don't think most people have to be under a fear that they can't eat raw
spent spot raw Spanish.
That's the thing.
I don't think there you need to fear eating Ross badge.
I think maybe just don't be a dumb ass and like,
you know,
go way,
way,
way overboard.
Right.
So,
you know,
eating some raw juices is probably really good for you.
Eating nothing but raw juices all day,
all your life.
It's not so good for you.
You need animal protein or some other things and yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
there was another guy I know of a guy who,
uh,
Brock Lesnar was actually the UFC heavyweight champion who eat nothing but meat.
He was a fucking crazy person and he got diverticulitis and he had to get a 12
inches of his colon removed.
Pretty serious operation.
It's really interesting that some,
no,
I don't know how much of a degree this is dose dependent,
but,
um,
there's bacteria in your gut called purification bacteria and they called that
because of the bacteria that make that really nasty smelling fart.
It's like hydrogen sulfide.
So I was like pure hydrogen sulfide and those bacteria,
the purification bacteria,
they actually use,
um,
like sulfate and nitrate as their source of energy.
And they convert it into like,
for example,
hydrogen sulfide,
but they need,
um,
they,
so it's the,
it's basically what we do with oxygen.
They do that with these sulfate and they,
they make it into hydrogen sulfide.
It's like us converting oxygen to water.
That's how we make ATP.
They do this by converting sulfate into hydrogen sulfide,
announce their energy,
this nutrification bacteria.
Well,
they need,
they need these,
um,
I guess cofactors to do this.
And that's heme.
Heme is in red meat.
And so some people that you really,
really large doses of red meat,
like what happens is you're giving those bacteria heme and they start to make
hydrogen sulfide.
And the thing with hydrogen sulfite,
so y'all met,
first of all,
you get future occasion of bacteria,
so you'll have nasty smelling farts like hydrogen sulfite farts.
Um,
and also hydrogen sulfide combat competitively competitively binds to enzymes in
our guts cells that make energy.
So they actually,
so it goes,
hydrogen sulfide goes and binds to these,
um,
electron transport chain enzymes that make ATP in our gut cells and
competitively inhibits them from actually being able to reduce oxygen to water
to make ATP.
So then your guts,
Dell start to like starve down there and starts to break down the gut mucous
barrier.
Anyways,
it's totally a tangent and I don't know how I got on that.
I guess the meat,
the,
the high meat diet,
right?
So the diverticulitis that people got from eating only meat.
Yeah.
So like I said,
I think it's a dose,
you know,
really just dependent
cause eating a little bit of meat.
It depends.
I mean,
you know,
your own body,
if you're eating tons of meat and you started smelling these hydrogen sulfide
smart farts,
that's not good.
Right.
Probably not.
Not Good.
So if you smell a guy as far,
you might die.
You should talk to,
but it's like,
it's not,
it's not the kind of Fart that,
you know,
it's the,
it's the pure,
those ones that are like,
oh good God.
Yeah,
it's that.
It's that one.
Yeah.
Stuff's going on.
Those are bodybuilding farts.
If you're on and they eat a lot of red meat.
Right.
Do they just won't buy a lot of protein,
period.
You know?
Does it affect all other types of proteins?
He,
him his,
and it's what gives red meat the red color.
Yeah.
It's specific to red meat.
So the more red meat,
the more horrible forest,
pretty much.
It makes sense.
It's like,
well,
what do you,
who do you think about having the worst farts?
It's always guys with big guts.
You know,
like if someone farts on an airplane,
you always look at the guy with the gut.
It's very difficult to figure out who's farting on an airplane.
It's one of the reasons people are so sneaky
about it.
Sneaky airplane,
foreigners.
He know who you are.
But the guys with the big guts,
they're usually the culprit.
It's,
I mean,
it's,
I mean that's,
it's the beautification bacteria.
Putrid vacation bacteria.
I mean,
they're named for a reason and they're,
it makes,
just want to throw up.
It does.
Um,
so often this is a,
you know,
my friend Brian Cowen,
who I love dearly,
but he's fucking ridiculous.
And he's one of those guys that will get on this tangent and listen to one
person say something and then spout it out as if it's fucking gospel.
And he hit me with this Peter off it guy?
Or is that the guy's name?
Paul?
Whatever the fuck doctor off it.
We've fuck his name is.
And he listened to this guy and without debunking it online at all,
and I did it real quick,
I did a real quick debunking of it and found a bunch of people called bullshit
on all of his claims.
Meanwhile,
these studies were from 1942 and it's just like so much of what this guy had
said,
what was horseshit?
Um,
one of them off it claim that a study,
but this guy was basically saying was that taking vitamins and taking
antioxidants can actually cause cancer.
And you know,
calen of course never wants to be wrong.
So he's telling me no,
no,
the all studies confirm this.
I'm like the fuck they do man.
And so I sent him all this,
this,
you know,
I,
I've barraged him with all these debunking sites and he backed off finally,
but for fucking days his Twitter was all about don't take Antioch's and he's,
he,
I'm really convinced,
no,
you fucking called me up.
He's like,
dude,
I'm really worried about you.
You're taking into accidents,
you taking vitamins and where are you going to get cancer?
I'm like,
the fuck are you talking about?
God,
we need it.
We need to dive into this.
I mean,
to me it angers me.
What was the name of the book he wrote?
It's do you believe it's called?
I'm a con.
That's his book.
I'm a cunt and I'm trying to make money cause that.
I think that's what's going on with a lot of these fuckheads,
these contrarians with these people that make these articles.
I don't know how many of them are just idiots.
I don't know how many of them were like Brian dunning where they just sort of,
they're,
they're mentally deficient.
There's something wrong with the way they're thinking worse and you know,
and I discovered that in communicating with Brian over three hours,
I'm like,
oh,
there's something wrong here and I don't know what it is and I don't want to
know what it is.
But it's obvious you're not normal.
You're not healthy.
You're,
your correlations are not healthy.
Like just just discussing buildings.
Falling is like his,
his way of looking at things is unhealthy.
It's not,
it's not correct.
I don't know if that's what this guy's doing.
I don't know if a lot of Nice people who are doing things,
I think they're just trying to get attention.
They're just like,
oh,
Kale is going to kill you.
Fucking kill is going to kill me.
Everybody knows that people are loving Kale these days.
People are finding these health benefits skills.
I tuck talk freely and openly about how I drink Kale Salads or Kale shakes
rather regular basis and how I feel great when I take him.
So,
and then,
you know,
people will sell him,
send me these fucking,
so I read tweets,
some of them,
and then I'll find contradictory articles.
I retweet those.
So there's off it fucking thing just drove me up a wall because I started
reading all the people that call bullshit on this guy and all these people that
say that he's kind of dangerous,
that the things he's saying are kind of dangerous because they're easily
refutable but he's trying to sell them.
You selling them,
selling them as fat.
Yeah.
So let me,
let me,
let's dig in here because I really,
um,
I was,
I,
first of all,
I wasn't familiar with the guy until you brought them to my attention.
And actually my p my advisor,
my postdoctoral advisories and 85 year old like world renowned scientist,
he knew who the guy was and he was like,
you're going to crush him.
Like he,
he really doesn't like this guy.
I mean,
he's familiar with his whole everything he's doing.
So that's why I was so angry at Cowen,
because if you go online,
there's just a fucking slew of reputable paypal,
right?
I think this guy's,
and no,
I didn't read his book,
but I listened to the podcast and I took notes on what he said and I'm ready.
Let's,
let's go through some of this because I think it's really important.
First of all,
he,
this guy makes huge over generalizations,
doesn't understand mechanism.
It's clear to me.
So the first thing,
the first thing he says is,
is that,
you know,
we should have,
if we're going to look at the effects of supplements,
we need to do randomized controlled trials.
We need to hold all drugs to the same standard.
We need to do randomized controlled trials.
So randomized controls,
controlled trials are like the poster child for pharmacological interventions,
drug interventions and what they are is you basically you get a population,
people,
you split them into two groups,
two groups and you're going to have either your,
your drug blah blah banal or placebo and you're going to give,
you know,
whichever group one drug,
blah,
Blah Blah and all the other groups per se.
But Oh and you don't know who's getting what.
They don't know who's getting what and men are going to look at some clinical
end point like heart attack or myocardial infarct infarction or something like
that.
And it's really a great design for that,
that sort of thing.
Because you know,
when you start off at baseline,
everyone in the trial has same levels of drug,
Blah Blah and all in their blood.
Guess what,
zero because we don't make drugs,
we don't eat drugs.
You know,
it's not something that we're,
you know,
eating on a daily basis.
This is at pharmacological drug that's been designed with a certain mechanism,
mechanism of action to act on a certain thing to do a certain thing,
right?
Like you know stands for example.
So you know,
you can do that where you have this randomized controlled trial for a certain x
amount of time and you look at the effect on heart attacks and you don't have to
measure anything.
You know,
the problem is is that you can't apply that same thinking for nutrition research
because everyone has different levels of vitamins and minerals in their body.
People eat different diets.
I mean,
you have people that are deaf,
you know,
have inadequate levels of things are deficient in certain things,
have optimal levels of certain things.
And so if you just take this random group of people,
put them into two groups and then give them a vitamin supplement and then try to
look at some clinical end point like heart attack.
Well guess what?
You're going to have people that have were severely deficient and whatever you
gave them,
they're still severely deficient.
Or you're going to have people that are top total adequate levels.
And you're getting,
giving them a vitamin.
They already have adequate levels up and you're trying to look at some clinical
end point.
You can't do nutrition research with the same mind frame where whereas we're
looking at we're going to do the same type of trial that we do for drugs.
You know,
that's just,
you can't do that.
You can't do that.
You have to think about the way you control and design a clinical trial.
And when you're doing nutrition research,
where you're,
where you're looking at the effects of vitamins and minerals,
first of all,
that there's two very different things going on when you have a pharmacological
drug,
your giving it to someone because they're already falling apart.
Okay?
They're already falling apart and you're trying to help them not fall apart as
fast by giving them something you know,
that blocks x or y or z or like cholesterol synthesis for one Stanton's,
um,
with vitamins and minerals.
These are things that are important for,
for,
for preventing you from falling apart.
These are things that we require these enzymes we need,
you know,
cofactors for enzymes that we need to do like hundreds of different
physiological functions,
thousands of different physiological functions.
You know,
so we're talking about a different start point,
right?
It's not,
it's not like you give people vitamins when they're falling apart.
No,
they know they need to be getting their vitamins to make sure they don't fall
apart,
you know?
And so the whole randomized controlled trial using that,
that's,
so he kept saying this like we need to hold vitamins to the same standard as
drugs.
We need to have randomized controlled trials.
And that's how we determine whether or not they're effective or their,
their,
their efficacy rate basically.
But like I said,
you can't do that.
You have to measure people's vitamin and mineral levels.
Let's like,
let's say you're looking at vitamin D at baseline to see how efficient they are.
For one,
this is going to determine the dose that you give them.
You know,
if someone's like 12 nanograms per milliliter and you give them 400 Ius a day,
they've even shown in that annals of internal medicine paper that doesn't work.
They're still going to be deficient at the end of the trial.
You can because you know,
400 Ius a day raises your blood levels by like five nanograms per milliliter.
So you can't just not the way to do
research,
the difference being that given someone something that's completely alien to the
body but could be beneficial like a drug or giving them something that is
absolutely essential to the body that is necessary and is a part of normal
everyday diet that you can't look at the two of them the same way that the drug
may help people,
but the reality is you're introducing something that's completely alien to the
person's system in order to benefit them.
Whereas with vitamins you are just regulating or measuring what is essential to
the human body and and,
and,
and pretty much has been established that vitamin B,
Vitamin D,
vitamin C,
all of these different things is that various aspects of nutrition are essential
to human health.
That's one,
that's one aspect of it.
You can't look at a drug the same way you look at vital.
Yeah.
And also,
like I said,
people already start off with varying levels of these vitamins.
So when you're randomizing them into two different populations,
you don't know.
Some of these people get up could be very deficient.
Some have plenty of vitaminK or whatever you're looking at.
So you need to measure them at baseline.
So you'd get a deficient population.
You need to get a population that's low because the whole point of,
you know,
giving someone a vitamin supplement is to bring them up to an adequate level.
It's not to like have some effect on top.
It's not like a drug where you're,
you know,
blocking some receptor and having some response.
No,
you're taking vitamins and mineral supplements because you're not getting
everything you need from your food and you want to get yourself up to an
adequate level.
And so what you need to do is start off,
you need to measure people's levels at baseline.
Start off with a population that's inadequate,
give them a vitamin and mineral supplement to get them to an adequate level.
And then you can measure something.
So it's really important,
and I think they even talked about this last time,
is quantifying these levels.
Well,
this is the reason why you can't,
you,
you know,
starting off with a population of people that has enough vitamin D and You're
trying to look at the effects of vitamin D on cancer incidents.
Well guess what?
You know,
they already have enough vitamin D they're already in is adequate range.
Or conversely,
if they're really,
really,
really deficient and you're looking at the effects of vitamin D and cancer
incidents,
and you give them a dose that still makes them,
they're still deficient.
Well,
guess what?
We don't know what,
how vitamin D is affecting cancer.
And since from that one study,
because they're still deficient at the end of the trial,
you know,
so the conclusion is,
oh,
my dose was inefficient,
was inadequate to bring them to an adequate level of vitamin D.
That's,
that should be the conclusion,
not,
oh,
vitamin D doesn't affect cancer incidents.
Right,
right.
Which is what people tend to do,
Eh,
you know,
you have to sell your story to get it published.
You know,
you do all,
you need years and years work of research and,
uh,
you find this negative data and it's like,
well,
you gotta sell it somehow so you're not going to sell it by saying,
oh,
well it didn't give them an adequate dose and they're still not,
you know,
up to adequate levels.
So that's,
that's really,
uh,
the one first thing about off it and so many others,
including the people that wrote that this whole and offers enough editorial.
Yeah,
there are the same,
they were looking at randomized control trials.
Most of the time they started off with people didn't measure anything at all at
start or throughout,
you know,
the,
the followups and you know,
it's like,
well,
well the enough is enough was even worse because enough is enough.
Where they were studying.
Two of the things that we're studying,
we're heart attacks and people over 65 and dementia did delaying the onset of
dementia in people who are over 65 like Jesus fucking Christ.
You're talking about people who are dying,
right?
And you're giving them vitamins and saying,
doc didn't stop them from dying.
Right?
You're dealing with compete completely broken human beings that are like on
death's door.
There's the forgetting shit.
They don't know where they are and their heart's failing.
And you're like,
God,
vitamins don't work.
So to say,
vitamins don't work in those two circumstances is ridiculous.
And there are other circumstance showed a slight improvement with vitamins,
and yet they still came to conclusion.
The vitamins don't work because that's the most title,
right?
They,
vitamins and minerals are important to prevent disease.
They are important to prevent disease.
You know,
it's not,
it's not like if you're already falling apart and you've already been deficient
for years and years and years and years and years,
guess what?
It's much harder to patch things up much more difficult.
You've already acquired so much damage.
You've acquired so many different things that are going wrong that trying to
patch it up later is really difficult.
And so you know,
in those studies also they did things where they were giving it to cancer
patients.
And like I said,
or if smokers,
they were looking at the effects of Beta carotene or vitamin A in smokers.
And the thing is is that smokers are a different breed because,
I mean they're taking in poison every day.
And what happens is their lungs,
they have a very oxidative environment.
So when they take vitamin Beta carotene,
which is part of the vitamin a family,
this Beta carotene gets cleaved because they have oxidative stress and stuff
going on.
It gets cleaved into some of these cleavage products which actually damaged DNA
more and Co and can accelerate cancer.
And,
but the thing is is that that's specific to smokers.
If you give the same dose of Beta carotene to a nonsmoker,
guess what?
That doesn't happen.
They don't get those cleavage products and it doesn't start damaged their DNA
more and it doesn't accelerate cancer.
So you know,
you have to really,
the context is so important.
Like,
you know,
you can't just say,
oh,
vitamin A's bad for you.
No.
Well,
if you're a smoker,
it's a,
you know,
this is a certain context where,
there can be problems with taking high doses of Beta carotene for that reason
where you're,
you're,
you've got all these oxidative stress things going on.
And so they cleave the Beta Beta carotene into the certain cleavage products
that normal people don't get.
You know,
so context is very important and this is something that so many people so often
ignore,
including off it.
Um,
you know,
another,
he,
he's basically states that,
and he says clear.
It's clear and consistent that antioxidant antioxidants,
supplements are bad for you and can give you cancer.
And he gives two examples.
The one example he says is the prostate cancer study.
And the second example he says is because you need oxidants around in your body
to prevent cancer cells,
it kills cancer cells.
Right.
Okay.
So it's kind of like,
well it's kind of a big overgeneralization and it really shows me his lack of
understanding,
his lack of understanding of mechanism either because it's too much work to look
into it because it's a lot of work or you know,
just because he doesn't care,
it's,
you know.
Um,
so let's start off with the first part.
He says,
you know,
vitamin E can cause prostate cancer.
This is,
this is huge.
This is actually,
there was a huge,
huge study called the uh,
select trial where they took the,
the selenium and vitamin E cancer prevention trial.
Selenium is also important.
It's a cofactor for about 25 or so different proteins that are one of them being
glued Oth I peroxidase and synthase and all these different antioxidant genes.
And it's been shown to selenium highest Linnaean was correlated with low cancer
incidents,
so they thought that would play a role in prostate cancer.
So they did this big trial where they got like someone like 30,000 men is pretty
big and they gave him supplements that gave them either vitamin e.
So vitamin E is actually,
there's a whole family of vitamin E's.
It's not just one vitamin,
there's actually eight different forms of it.
And uh,
Alpha Beta,
Gamma Delta,
and there's the present is either tocopherols or took her adrenals tribunals,
and the major forms are Alpha and gamma tocopherol.
Okay.
And these two different forms of vitamin E,
the Alpha and gamma tocopherol there,
they're antioxidants,
but they actually have separate functions.
So the Alpha Tocopherol is a very potent antioxidant,
so it's very good at,
you know,
getting oxygen,
reactive oxygen radicals that's generated by like normal metabolism.
These things damage your DNA,
but they also damage your lipid,
like Byler of your membranes,
cell membranes.
What happens is vitamin D is fat soluble,
so it gets him those lipid by layers and it prevents the,
that oxygen radical from damaging it.
And what happens is if you don't have that happening,
your lip and membranes get stiffer and stiffer over time.
And this is part of aging where you're,
you're,
they become rigid and it's hard to transport metabolites into your cells.
It's hard to transport proteins in and out.
It just,
it screws up stuff.
So it's important to have,
you know,
something like five Alpha Tocopherol preventing that from happening.
It also prevents your proteins from being oxidized,
which causes problems.
So that's really important to have.
You know,
and you actually need to get it from your diet.
The vitamin E's you have to get from your diet,
from plants.
We don't make it ourselves.
The gamma form actually is also an antioxidant,
but it's an anti nitration one.
So nitration is formed from your immune system.
Just normal immune function,
like,
you know,
fighting off things creates reactive nitrogen species.
So these nitrogen species also do the same thing as oxygen species.
They damage your DNA,
the damage,
your lipid membranes,
the damaged proteins in your body.
So having both Alpha Tocopherol and the Gamma Tocopherol,
they're doing two independent functions is important because they're making sure
you're not getting those oxygen or nitrogen reactive species damaging crap in
your body basically.
Okay.
And that's important to prevent cancer,
to prevent,
you know,
a lot of diseases of aging.
So protein said begin,
come or get nitrated aggregate and they can form you know,
things and plaques in your brain.
They can cause neurodegenerative diseases.
So it's,
it's important to have,
you know,
these antioxidant mechanisms in place to prevent that from happening as we age.
Okay.
So with that said,
the Alpha Tocopherol and you can see how complex this is.
You know,
the Alpha Tocopherol is the major form in your tissues and in your bloodstream.
But the problem is is that when you take really high levels of it,
so the Rda is like 22.4 I use,
when you take really high like 10 times at like 400 I use,
what happens is it depletes your gamma levels.
Okay.
And this has been well known for like over a decade.
Multiple labs have shown this,
including the lab I work in and they showed it in many years ago before I even
joined their lab.
So you know,
taking high,
high levels of Alpha can be bad because it depletes the gamma and the gamma has
a separate function from the alpha.
It prevents that nitration.
It also is an antiinflammatory,
inhibits Cox enzymes,
which are involved in generating prostoglandins.
So what they did was they gave men either Alpha to cough or all 400 I'd use.
So 10 times the Rda,
maybe even one in 10 times.
And salinium.
Okay.
So they give them either outfit to cough or all salinium only or both Alpha
Tocopherol insulin,
IOM or the placebo.
And then they looked,
they followed up,
they did a couple of followups to look at prostate cancer incidents.
Okay.
So the first study was about five and a half year follow up.
And this was published in like 2009 and what it found was there's no effect
taking vitamin E had no effect on cancer incidents.
Taking selenium had no effect.
But what they,
what you can see if you look at the data is they measured their alpha and gamma
levels at baseline.
And then at five and a half years,
what happened was those men taking 400 I use depleted their gamma tocopherol by
like 45% at the end of the followup,
which is like crazy.
That's not good.
Um,
and then the second followup,
what it found is it's seven and a half years later they found that,
oh my goodness,
the men taking,
you know,
400 I use of Alpha Alpha tocopherol had a 17% increase risk of prostate cancer.
And then they went on to say,
oh my goodness,
you know,
400 I use a vitamin e a day can cause prostate cancer.
However,
the men taking the selenium with the vitamin,
he didn't get it.
So the men taking that outfit to cough for all by itself,
but took once it took with the selenium with it didn't get it.
So that salinium protected and they didn't know why.
So another study then recently came out from the sand.
This is all the same big cohort of people found that only the men that were
severely deficient in selenium to start the trial that took the Alpha Tocopherol
or the ones that had the increased cancer incidents.
So I started thinking about this,
well,
why is that selenium also is important is uh,
like I said,
it's important for pro like 25 or so proteins.
One of them is important for preventing nitration reactive nitration products.
So it was like,
wow,
well this makes sense.
You're taking high levels of outfits,
coffer,
all depleting your gamma levels,
which is important to get rid of nitration damage,
right?
Which damages DNA,
causes cancer,
things like that.
And yet you can give someone this salinium Irmaa if they're,
if they're not deficient in selenium,
that doesn't happen.
And so one of the selenium proteins also does that.
So the bottom line is,
does taking,
you know,
normal levels of Alpha Tocopherol like 22 or 30,
I use a day,
deplete your gamma levels?
No.
Is it,
is it good for you?
Like,
is it going to prevent your op,
you know,
lipid membranes from oxidizing and your DNA from getting oxidized yest uh,
is it going to give you cancer?
No,
it's actually the opposite.
Prevents cancer is taking high,
high levels of of Alpha Tocopherol dangerous?
Well it can be,
yes,
because it depletes your gamma.
So you know,
taking high levels of Alpha to call for all is not a,
is not a good thing because it can deplete your gamma,
but that's only if you're also selenium deficient.
It's very,
very complicated.
It is not simple and it's not as simple as taking vitamin E is going to give you
cancer.
No.
There's a whole host of complex mechanisms that are at play here.
And,
and the reality is,
you know,
if you want to,
60% of the population doesn't have enough Alpha Tocopherol.
Okay.
60%.
So if you,
if you want to supplement with it,
just don't be dumb.
Take a take a lower level of and supplement with the mix.
You can buy a mixed tocopherols together.
So they get the Alpha,
the GAM,
and the Beta.
What does a good source of that?
Um,
so ABA,
Cahtos,
Pecans,
walnuts,
plant plant sources.
I like to get my,
I almonds also.
So I also,
I get my vitamin E,
uh,
mostly from,
from plant sources.
And also I use almond milk,
unsweetened almond milk in my smoothies.
Like I said,
I make a really big smoothie every morning,
which has all these different micronutrients.
Yeah.
And Sweden is the key really.
Right.
I have a friend who said,
oh,
I'm,
it looks amazing.
I'm not drinking milk.
And more,
I'd say so good.
I go,
okay,
okay.
What is it?
What kind of flavor is it?
And he was at vanilla.
Go look at the fucking label please.
I go,
what does it say as far as grams of sugar,
right.
19 grams of sugar per serving.
Yeah.
You have to get the unsweetened,
you have to get the unsweetened,
but it has,
it has a lot of magnesium in it and about a lot of the,
uh,
the mixed vitamin E,
so it's,
it's a good source.
So vitamin E
limitation in your opinion,
you should probably just get it from diet to make sure that your levels are a
normal healthy levels.
And then it's the balance of the different types of vitamin A's.
Yeah,
I prefer getting it from Diet.
You,
there are mixed tocopherols that you can buy that are low.
It's not like a 10 times the RDA and their mix.
So you're getting the gamma with the alpha.
So if you have a good source for that,
um,
I think there's Swanson brand may have a good one.
Uh,
is that what you mean by a yeah,
like a brand company.
Yeah.
And then you know that I think that might be a one one,
I can't recall off the top of my head,
but they are pretty reliable in general.
Um,
you know,
in a sense he oversimplified things,
but there is a danger of taking too many vitamins when you're taking vitamins,
like a vitamin E that could potentially,
if you're taking one form of it,
that could potentially deplete your,
your,
uh,
absorption of the other.
Exactly.
If you're taking a really,
really high dose of vitamin the Alpha Tocopherol,
vitamin E,
uh,
there could be a potential danger and it depleting the gamma form.
And
anyone know whether they're taking alpha or gamma,
if it just have a,
if you look,
if you have a vitamin e container and look on the back of it,
it'll say,
it'll say like Alpha Tocopherol,
it'll say this sort,
like it says Alpha or gamma.
Most supplemental forms are Alpha.
And,
and that's because that's the predominant species found in tissues and in
plasma.
So people,
you know,
we thought it was like the,
the most important,
but we found that gamma is also really important.
Um,
and,
but you can buy mixed tocopherols,
you know,
you can buy mixed tocopherols.
Okay.
So that is just one thing that he brought up that was incorrect.
Well,
that,
yeah,
so that was one he made.
He said the data is clear and consistent.
And for one that's anything but clear.
I mean there's lots of complex things going on and he said that it,
you know,
it's clear and consistent that supplemental antioxidants cause cancer.
Well,
there's also other studies showing that,
you know,
these,
uh,
p profit of PR in,
in the case of prostate cancer,
if you look at their blood levels of Alpha,
tocopherol and gamma,
those with the highest levels of Alpha and gamma have the least,
you know,
prostate cancer incidents.
So there's inconsistency in terms of what exactly is going on and we're still
really understanding all the muck,
trying to understand all the mechanisms at play.
Um,
but he also,
he also made the overgeneralization and that taking supplemental antioxidants is
bad because you need pro oxidants to kill cancer cells.
And that was like the second part of his why supplemental antioxidants are bad.
And you know,
this is another example of context.
So you know,
if you,
if you don't have enough of the Alpha Gamma Tocopherols,
then you're going to have increased DNA damage.
You're going to have,
you know,
things that caused mutations and what happened.
You know,
what happens is you're going to,
you know,
accumulate that over time and that's going to lead to cancer.
So not having enough of this vitamin D is not good.
And like I said,
60% of the population doesn't have enough.
Um,
but the flip side is,
is that if you already have cancer,
then taking supplemental vitamin E,
uh,
what happens is because it prevents that oxidation,
then you,
uh,
there's mechanisms in your body that induce cell death.
When you have oxidation,
when you have this damage,
sturdy DNA tumor suppressor genes get activated and they kill the cell.
So what they've shown is that in mice,
if you take mice that already,
if you give him cancer and you'd give them supplemental vitamin E,
you can attenuate that whole pathway,
that that activates the cell,
the death of these cancer cells.
Uh,
but that's not the case.
If you take a mouse,
it doesn't have cancer and you give them vitamin E,
it actually prevents the DNA damage.
So this is a case where you're looking at context.
So someone that doesn't have,
you know,
that is not,
it doesn't have cancer on their body.
You want to make sure the not causing DNA damage,
which is happening,
you know,
every second by making sure they have enough of these antioxidants.
But on the flip side of that,
you know,
if you already have cancer,
taking a bunch of supplemental vitamin E is not a good thing because you
couldn't attend.
You wait that pathway that is important to kill cancer cells.
So it's another thing where it's like context is so important.
You need to differentiate people that
are normal,
healthy and people that are trying to prevent themselves from getting cancer by
preventing these things that cause cancer,
which vitamin E can help prevent versus talking about someone that already has
cancer.
And so it was just incredibly irresponsible to make a simplified version of
these incredibly complex processes that are going on.
In my opinion.
It's,
it's,
it's a big,
big overgeneralization and uh,
it's probably because dive in deep into this stuff is it takes time and it's
complex and you need to understand how some of these things are interacting and
working,
you know,
so it's much easier to be like,
oh,
you read,
you read the study,
the conclusions and Oh yeah,
that's it.
That's the thing that people love to the love when someone can break it down and
the clear sentence.
Antioxidants can cause cancer while let me get on Twitter and let everybody know
that they're being an idiot.
Right.
I mean people love doing that.
They love saying things like that.
That like a nice,
clear,
concise,
easy to digest.
You know,
a low,
high alkaline diet kills cancer.
Oh,
I didn't even know.
I'm just going fucking me.
I don't think there was any possible way I could boil that down into like one
sentence didn't seem like it could.
Biology is very complex and trying to oversimplify it isn't necessarily a meat.
It doesn't necessarily mean you have a good understanding of the complexities.
This is certainly going to be a podcast.
It requires a notepad.
Yeah.
I have to do a lot of googling.
It's,
you know,
the,
the whole Alpha Tocopherol and gamma tocopherol it's,
it's something I think is important for people to,
to understand.
Um,
you know,
it is Alpha Tocopherol is the major supplemental form.
And the last study I show sauce said something about like 11% of the population
takes high levels of Alpha Tocopherol.
So you know,
you have a certain percent of the population that's going overboard and they
probably don't know about the effects that that's going on.
You know,
the,
the depletion of their gamma and how that can be bad.
So I think it is important for those people to realize that.
But the flip side,
you know,
someone like off it,
his solution to that is he wants to have high dose vitamins,
FDA regulated so that people like him who happened MD can prescribe them.
And so that's his solution to,
you know,
high dose vitamins and yeah,
it's,
if you think about it,
first of all,
you know who's going to define what a high dose is.
Is it the RDA?
Because if you look at something like vitamin D,
You know,
but right now the RDA for vitamin D is like 600 Ius a day and 70% of the
population doesn't have enough vitamin D and taking 600 I use a day if you're
deficient,
isn't going to get you to an adequate level.
So that's not a good level.
What is a good level of vitamin D?
If 600 is not an accurate level,
what's a,
what's an accurate level?
So,
you know,
in a couple of studies that I've read where people that were deficient in
vitamin D,
uh,
took 4,000 Ius a day for a year.
That was enough to get them up to 30 nanograms per milliliter,
which was a year.
It took a year.
Holy Shit.
And well,
it takes a long,
they,
well they did.
They measured it after a year.
So it,
it's possible if they had done some time points maybe in between,
uh,
that it,
it could have raised their levels higher than that,
a slow absorption into the body or something.
Like,
why would it take so long to,
to get the levels,
I'm not saying it's going to take a year,
it's just the way the study was designed.
They measured it a year later.
So,
uh,
it's,
you know,
it's possible that didn't take a year,
but the study was that they looked at it a year later after taking a year of a
4,000,
nine years day.
But that was enough.
Um,
I think generally speaking,
you know,
people that are supplementing between 2000 and 4,000 I use generally tend to
have adequate levels if they're not severely,
severely deficient to start with.
If you're severely,
severely division,
it can take longer to get up to an adequate status.
What are the other things that,
off it said that you didn't think were,
uh,
were accurate or were problematic?
Yeah.
So he also said that the data is clear and consistent that supplemental vitamins
don't do anything.
There's no positive benefit from them.
That's what he said,
no positive benefit.
And like I said,
to his credit,
I haven't read his book,
so maybe he goes into some specifics that I'm not aware of.
However,
to say that supplemental vitamins have no benefit is like really,
you know,
I mean they've done,
they've even done randomized controlled trials showing that Omega three fatty
acid supplementation supplementation lowers all cause mortality.
So you know,
supplementing and he actually refers to omega three fatty acids as an
antioxidant,
at least in that podcast he did.
So you know that that's one thing.
Vitamin D supplements,
people that are supplemented with vitamin D two 1500 ius a day.
Um,
I don't remember how long they did that for it,
but they had a 17,
it was many years that there was a 17% decrease in cancer cancer risk and there
was a 30% decrease in cancer mortality and like a 40% decrease in,
in camp,
uh,
cancers of the digestive system including colon cancer.
So that's one for vitamin D.
Alycia what's another one?
There was another study where they looked at a multivitamin that took
multivitamin and a,
but this was not a controlled trial.
This was,
they did questionnaire and found out like how many,
how frequently women took multivitamins and how,
how many times a day or how,
how many days a week they took them.
And what they found is that the ones that took vitamins on a daily basis had the
longest telomeres they measured to them or length.
So that's another one,
a magnesium.
So we're talking about,
you know,
taking supplemental vitamins helps you fill some of those nutritional gaps that
you're not getting from your diet.
And,
and the reality is is that we're not getting a lot of those vitamins and
minerals from our diet.
We talked about this a little bit when it's possible to eat a completely healthy
diet and get everything you need,
or do you need to supplement?
I mean,
is it possible?
Good question.
I don't know.
I mean like things like vitamin D,
what would you have to demean?
I know some milk you'd half well supple yet for vitamin D,
You'd have to really be living in a place that was exposed to the UBB during
winter and summer and you'd have to be out in the sun for 15 minutes,
you know,
cause getting it from fish,
well maybe fish has a a good,
good bit of it,
but you'd have to eat fish every day and also to get the Omega threes you'd have
to eat fish like everyday.
They don't make it.
Three fatty acids are another big one and you'd have to eat quite a bit of fish,
right.
In certain fish,
like salmon,
salmon,
like fatty fish.
Right,
exactly.
You'd have to eat like fatty fish.
So I think it would be really difficult.
Like I personally,
I tr I agree with,
with Offit and uh,
that goofball downing in some instances where you know,
you,
you should try to get all your micronutrients much as you can from your diet.
I agree.
You know,
and you know,
case and point my,
I do my smoothie.
I,
you know,
I definitely try to eat my greens and healthy,
healthy meats and fish.
I really like fish,
but I do supplement,
you know,
I take omega three fatty acids,
I take vitamin D,
I take a Multivitamin,
which has my,
you know,
selenium and some of my trace elements,
my iodine and uh,
what else do I take a,
I also take a B complex,
even though most people aren't,
they don't have low levels of,
of the B vitamins due to like fortification and stuff.
Now I actually take a B complex because,
um,
it's really kind of interesting,
but we are,
our lab has shown that,
well,
it's partly shown this,
that as we age I,
I talked about how your lipid membranes get more rigid and a lot of,
so this includes your mitochondrial membranes.
They get more stiff and uh,
over time what happens is,
uh,
metabolites and stuff can't get transported as easy.
And also what happens is these proteins there,
they bind co factors like B vitamins are really important for a lot of proteins.
In the Mitochondria that are necessary for metabolism to generate ATP.
And these proteins required B vitamins and a lot of them are embedded in the
membrane.
So when the membrane gets stiff,
the protein binding constant changes to that B vitamin and it's been shown that
you can overcome that,
meaning you actually can overcome that,
uh,
it messing up that binding constant because it screws up the structure of the
protein by increasing the level of B vitamins.
So what level to do recommend?
Like what,
uh,
what's the,
what's The u s the Rda and what do you think should for B vitamins?
You know,
I don't,
there's no telling what it should be there.
There's just no empirical data to show,
uh,
how much more you would need to a much come back.
I have a B complex and I just can't recall off the top of my head what all the,
cause there's so many of the,
of the B vitamins.
Do you know what the name of your B complexes that you take right now?
Right now I have one from vitacost,
but I've been switching over to Swanson brand because I spelled out Swanson like
w a n s o n.
There.
They're pretty reliable.
They've been around for a really long time.
Um,
they,
they generally have some,
some reliables I supplements for Omega Three.
I like Nordic naturals.
Um,
they're really good in Nordic naturals.
what is,
uh,
what,
that's a fish bait.
Fish oil.
So there's some oils.
Here's the,
here's the,
I'm the Swanson.
It has [inaudible],
uh,
25,
25 milligrams of Riboflavin,
which is 1471% of the U.
S r d a thigh Amanu Simon,
Simon,
which is B one.
It does 25 milligrams,
which is 1667% of the U.
S r d a,
vitamin C.
It hasn't been as well in the B complex.
So it was vitamin C,
which is interesting.
As you're saying,
833% of the US RDA and the other big one,
vitamin B six is 1250% and vitamin B,
12 2080 3% of us RDA.
That's interesting.
I've always found that interesting.
When you look at some vitamins,
you look at multivitamins and you know,
you know what the RDA is and you see their percentages fucking off the charts.
Yeah.
They have 2000% of the U Rda has be 12.
You know,
[inaudible] is a knucklehead.
I mean that's what they're saying.
And their company,
well look,
fuck them.
In the case of item a,
the B vitamins,
you know,
like I said,
most people,
um,
aren't,
aren't deficient and,
and they haven't really shown any toxicity of and taking too much of these B
vitamins and they are water soluble.
So you end up duping your being and all that.
I personally,
uh,
I'm taking them just because I've seen,
you know,
some of this data where it shows that some of these proteins that are when
you're a member let your lipid biolayer is kind of more rigid and gets screwed
up,
but you know,
over time and also when your oxidation does that are eating rancid fat,
things like that.
Um,
change is some of the structure of those membrane proteins that require B
vitamins.
And like I said,
I don't know how much more you need there.
It'd be cool to do a study to figure that out,
but it's not a dangerous one because they're water soluble.
It's an it ha.
I haven't seen any data that shows it to,
it's a dangerous one for one because they are water soluble and you pee them
out.
What are the fat soluble ones that we should be careful about?
Overdosing Alpha Tocopherol is one.
Right?
Right.
Like I said,
the whole interplay between the gamma and Alpha,
you know,
is uh,
so gamma,
Tocopherol,
Alpha Tocopherol,
all,
all the ease.
Those are fat soluble,
right?
He also should be careful.
Vitamin D you can,
you know,
you can't take too much.
I,
you,
if you take
the toxicity levels that,
that I've seen have been shown that like 10,000 Ius a day for some time that,
anything over that,
and actually I think it even is quite higher than that.
But that's the limit of toxicity.
What about a mega threes and Omega threes in plant based form versus in fish
form?
Great question.
So if you look at the,
uh,
so meg us,
there's three,
there's EPA,
there's Dha and Ala.
So the major plant form like flaxseed oil or flax seed walnuts for example,
have Ala.
Okay.
And that's,
they don't have EPA or Dha.
Now you can convert a very small percentage of a l a l a n to the EPA,
but it's like 5% of it.
It's very inefficient conversion.
Um,
and women may be able to do a little bit better of a conversion.
I can't recall off the top of my head what their number was.
But the point is is that um,
if your only source of Omega three is flax or you know,
walnuts,
you're not getting your Dha,
you hear that vegans.
Yeah,
that's really I the vegans.
If you're a Vegan,
really I just micro algae oil.
I mean the phytoplankton are essentially,
or what making these Omega three is to fish,
eat the phytoplankton and gets contract and fat micro algae oil.
I recommend for people that are vegetarian,
Vegan,
Michael algae oil and,
but when you're eating micro algae oil [inaudible] totally constitutes Vegan.
Is there any sort of animal protein and micro algae oil?
I guess your,
you know,
well they're phyto plankton so if you're vegan based off of philosophy where you
don't want to eat like any type of creature.
Yeah,
phytoplankton is Fido creature.
It is,
it's kind of a great teacher.
But so that,
I guess that could be a problem.
But if you are doing,
if you're a vegetarian or Vegan for health purposes and there's not like a
philosophical component where you know,
you have a problem with eating the spider plankton,
then
well shamine vegans shouldn't avoid.
Uh,
I mean there's certain probiotics that are,
I mean,
that's a creature to
true
living life.
Yeah,
no,
that's a good point.
I don't know.
But they move,
I mean they're,
they're active,
they're active.
They are absolutely.
Just because you can't see them.
I mean you're,
you're basically in little tiny turtles or something,
you know,
whatever.
So the little moving thing,
right.
You know,
I don't know what the philosophy,
because I don't have a lot of Vegan friends and it's really no cut those people
out of your life.
It's very important.
[inaudible] against them.
I just,
you know,
either by like fucking with them.
So,
but the Omega three,
Dha and EPA are really important.
They're really,
really important.
And so you asked,
can you take too much?
I mean for one,
you know,
EPA is a very,
it's got a very
potent anti inflammatory effect,
which is you know,
important for a variety of different mechanisms.
You know,
inflammation,
chronic inflammation over time can lead to a lot of age related diseases and Dha
as we I think even discussed last time,
it's a really important component of your cell membranes,
particularly in the brain,
like 40% of it.
So I took a lot of,
I take a lot,
I speak a lot to how much she took a day.
So well it depends.
So you have to look,
okay,
you got your fish oil container and on the front it says like 1000 milligrams or
of mine says 2,120 or something.
And then you turn around in the back and you look at the break,
the breakdown.
Okay,
how much EPA,
how much DPA,
a Dha.
And then there's other fish oils mixed.
So on my container it says like 200 or 2,100 and something.
And I turned on the back,
it's got 800 milligrams of EPA and 600 milligrams of Dha.
So,
and then all the rest is just fish oil,
fish oil stuff.
So I actually calculate how much I take based on those components,
the EPA and Dha because that's important.
That's what's important to me.
So I take about six pills of those a day and a serving size,
I guess a serving size is two.
So a little bit more than that.
I took 10 10 pills.
Okay.
And you're,
that's pretty cool.
I've done that.
I mean I've done that in the past.
It has a big impact on joint health has a big impact for uh,
for grapplers,
for Jujitsu,
people are always getting sore knees and elbows is a big issue and even sore
backs and it has a huge impact on that.
The antiinflammatories absolutely,
absolutely.
What is the anti inflammatory,
what does the actual mechanism,
the anti inflammatory mechanism involved in fish oil?
So the,
the EPA is the major part.
So you can actually by EPA,
like just,
you know,
there's,
there's companies that will sell.
If you're really just looking at the anti inflammatory part of the fish oil,
you can buy EPA.
It's a little more expensive.
But what it does is it inhibits that whole [inaudible] acid pathway,
which produces prostoglandins.
So it's like,
it's like upstream where it's,
it's inhibiting the production of [inaudible] acid and then prostoglandins which
activate Cox.
It like,
Oh,
you know,
you've got this whole cascade of inflammation going on.
It plays a major role,
not,
and there's probably other mechanisms I haven't even read about,
you know,
other things going on as well.
Uh,
that I,
I'm not even sure,
you know,
feedback mechanisms,
stuff like that.
But that's the major way that EPA does.
And they've been shown that like taking two grams of EPA a day can lower it can
like reduce your c reactive protein levels.
Oh Gosh.
I don't remember the exact amount by how much it was,
but it was pretty significant where it's like,
it really,
you can measure,
it lowers inflammation system,
like systemic inflammation.
How many thousand milligrams or a gram,
you just said it.
1000 milligrams are in one gram,
2000 milligrams.
Two grams.
Yeah.
Why don't they just call a gram?
Well,
they have to call it no room.
I usually can get to a thousand.
It's much easier.
Yeah,
it's quite confusing to me.
Maybe because people aren't aware of the whole metric system and stuff.
So if they see two grams,
you're like,
oh,
well that's nothing.
That's just too,
well,
we've,
people get confused because we go ounces all the time with so many different
things.
Why we,
I don't understand why we use the metric system in some cases.
In some cases we don't at all leaders.
Oh,
it's a leader.
Well how many courses in their own fuck?
I don't know.
He could look Pfizer court in the leader.
What are you doing to me here?
Well,
in the lab we do everything.
Milliliter liter.
I mean,
so gallons.
When you go to the gas station,
I don't even see that.
I always have to Google.
How many inches will try to fucking,
I'm night 90 centimeters.
What the fuck is 96 how tall is that?
I don't even know.
You know what I mean?
If someone tried to get someone's height in centimeters.
So is your fish oil that you take,
is it both EPA and Dha?
That's a good question.
I take this Carlson's Carlson,
do you take the lemon flavored one in the bottle or do you take them in pills?
I take both.
I bring the pills with me.
When I go on the road,
I took the lemon and the bottle at home.
Okay.
Yeah.
There,
there is something to be aware of with the omega three fatty acids and that's
because they're poly unsaturated fatty acids.
They're very prone to oxidation.
So keeping them at four degree,
well keeping them in the fridge,
sorry,
lowers that,
that oxidation process and also just smelling it,
take,
take a sniff of it and make sure it's not rancid smelling when you're taking,
when you're taking it because that's the one thing.
Um,
with the omega three fatty acids.
And like I said,
I take a lot of omega three fatty acids and I think they're really important.
But I think it's important to be aware that they can go rancid and,
and if it go ranted,
consuming them can be not as good.
And when you leave them in the frigerator,
how long is it good for when you crack open that bottle?
I've always given it a two week window.
If I don't drink it in two weeks,
I throw it out is that I don't use the bottle,
uh,
any more.
But the bottle is more pro is more open to be oxygen.
So that is one thing to be aware of with,
with the bottle.
And that was what the pills,
that was something that I think that was part of the reason why I switched to
it.
That and I think I got really sick of that lemon flavor.
It gets kind of fun.
It's kind of much,
yeah.
So it's easier to just not taste anything and you swallow the pills,
but then you're dealing with the gelatin as well.
It's still too spot.
I haven't convinced myself that it's doing my charm,
but who knows.
Maybe I,
maybe I haven't dug deep enough.
What about Krill oil?
How do you feel about crude oil?
Um,
I haven't really done much,
much reading on the Krill is that,
that has vitamin A as well or that's caught.
I'm thinking I'm conflating cod.
Cod liver oil was the one that they always gave us when we're kids.
And everybody was like,
get that away from tried it.
Like the taste.
I think I've had a pill and I couldn't really tell.
I actually think I have crude oil here.
Hold on.
Sorry.
Let me hold.
Yeah.
But uh,
you know,
taking,
taking the Omega three and just popping it open every once in a while and
smelling it is a good idea.
I recommend doing that because you can smell what rancid fats smells like.
So that's what I like to do.
And every once in a while I'll just grab my Omega three pill out of the fridge
and take some scissors,
cut it open and smell it.
And a,
if it doesn't smell rancid,
that's still good.
Yeah,
I've got some krill telling him about that
is um,
well krill oil,
I don't know what's supposed to be the benefit of Krill oil over here.
Fish oils have a lot of Dha or EPA on it.
No,
I mean it says 75 milligrams of Dha and 130 milligrams of EPA and that's too
soft gel servings.
So you think that fish oil is probably a better choice.
Thanks oil.
Okay.
Well,
I don't know if there's,
there's also one gram of Krill oil,
so it says one gram of Krill oil.
Maybe there's something in there I'm not aware of because I really,
I just haven't done a lot of research on,
but I'm looking at the Dha and EPA specifically.
If you're taking this to get Dha and EPA,
I would say this is not a very high amount.
So you think that if there is something good about Krill oil,
you should probably,
what lessons?
Why is it this thing's Krill oil radically better than fish oil.
Hmm.
Blood sugar regulator.
I don't know anything about it,
unfortunately.
There's some other reasons.
Maybe there's something else.
Yeah.
Like I said,
I'm,
I'm completely ignorant on
here.
On this website.
Krill oil actually influences your metabolism and a jeans to improve.
The reference study found that although both fish oil and Krill oil contain
Omega threes,
they differ greatly in how they affected genes.
Controlling your metabolism,
Krill oil enhances glucose metabolism in your liver,
whereas fish oil does not.
A krill oil promotes lipid metabolism or as fish oil does.
Dot.
Krill oil helps regulate the mitochondrial respiratory chain,
whereas fish oil does.
So Dha does do those things.
So when they're saying fish oil,
what are they talking?
They're talking shit.
Well,
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure I'm following.
I'm not either because Dha does regulate lipid lipid metabolism and also,
so let's,
so Dha and EPA in addition to to,
um,
the,
the anti inflammatory effects of EPA and in addition to the,
the lip,
a lipid membrane,
part of the Dha,
these fatty acid molecules are signaling molecules that actually bind to
different,
uh,
DNA regions in your gene and activate them.
A much like vitamin D does.
And Dha and EPA do this.
So Dha can,
can activate genes.
So you know,
if they're talking about,
and they've been shown to activate mitochondrial metabolism genes.
So when they say Krill oil and fish oil does not,
they're just,
it doesn't make any sense to me.
You have to be specific.
What is it you're talking,
are you talking about Dha because they're in,
but you know what else is there?
Yeah.
This is an article from Mercola.
Is that a good website?
You know,
Mercola is a hit or miss.
I think he does have a lot of good.
Every once in a while there's something,
you know,
it's both.
I haven't spend a lot of time reading his stuff.
Um,
but I do think he does.
He does have some good information,
but
doesn't sound like Krill oils bath.
But it does seem like fish oil is probably more beneficial or pro.
Well,
there's other things in here.
What's in it?
Yeah,
so the point is you have to be specific.
If you're saying just krill oil,
well,
you talking about other things in the Krill oil because if we're talking about
gene activation to DPA and Dha,
Dha is doing that.
Dee Dee Dha is activating genes.
You know,
it's,
that's,
that's what it's doing in addition to what it's doing for your [inaudible].
Yeah.
This is so confusing after reading what you said,
because it's saying some studies have shown the Krill oil,
Krill oil may be 48 times more potent than fish oil.
It means you will need far less of it than fish oil is confirmed by a 2011 study
for it.
48 times more potent.
In what sense?
Yeah.
What are we talking about in the Krill oil?
I just don't understand.
That's the problem.
And people have mortgages,
they have jobs,
they have children,
they have dogs to feed,
they have a plant water.
They don't fuck and time to get into all this stuff.
You know,
it's,
I feel bad for people.
I mean it's hard enough for me.
You're a person who is talking about,
I mean,
no,
it's cause it's craziness.
It's craziness.
And the reality is understanding mechanism.
Like what I'm saying,
mechanism I'm talking about Dha can activate,
you know,
promoters and certain genes to,
to increase the expression of mitochondrial metabolism genes that's been shown.
And uh,
so when you say Krill oil is better,
can do that in fish oil.
Can't,
that makes no sense to me.
You need to tell me what specifically is and the Krill oil that's not in fish
oil out because you know,
Dha and EPA are in fish oil.
Right?
Are we talking about a concentration dependent thing?
I mean,
is there a more Dha and EPA in Krill oil?
I don't know actually.
Yeah,
I don't,
yeah,
I think this is something that's going to have to be really studied in,
in length and a,
I would love to see you,
uh,
dive into all these claims,
but there's quite a few claims online about the benefits of crow oil over fish
oil,
but it doesn't,
it the,
one of the things that st quote,
cool oil contains asset tax.
Ooh,
boy.
Try this one at a s.
Tax.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a mouthful.
Tax.
The,
a unique marine sourced flavonoid that creates a special bond with the EPA and
Dha,
which allows direct metabolism of the antioxidants,
make them more bioavailable.
Does that make sense?
No.
Does that sound like Malarkey?
Possibly.
It doesn't make sense.
Yeah,
they did that.
It really is the issue,
isn't it?
There's just so much to try to sift through,
find out how to separate the wheat from the chaff I was at where it's,
yeah.
With,
with the Dha and EPA,
some really important thing in my opinion is getting it,
getting it up a bit,
like getting,
you know,
taking,
taking the good bed of,
of Dha and EPA because most people aren't getting any of it and all this other
stuff.
Um,
I'm just not sure how significant it is.
Maybe it does increase bioavailability of a little bit.
I don't,
I don't know if it really makes a big difference.
Uh,
so,
so for the folks that are taking the gear or they're getting their omega threes
s just completely from a plant source,
what can they do,
if anything to try to,
I really think the micro algae oil is the best.
I mean,
I would,
I would recommend taking the fish oil,
but I guess they won't do that.
Some cases vegetarians won't do that.
Um,
so the micro algae oil is the next best thing in my opinion.
and like I said,
I don't really know much about about the Krill oil,
but I do know that these Dha,
Dha is very important as is EPA.
So you know,
a variety of different reasons.
Well,
I'm going to send you some of these studies on,
on the Krill oil to see if you,
unless you get bored reading it and you can't do it.
It's,
there's just,
it seems like it's just such a boy,
it's such a mess.
It's such a,
there's so many different supplements then just going into all the contradictory
arguments,
the back and forth about all these different ones.
It can be incredibly taxing.
What's the,
I mean your website is a great resource or this,
um,
if,
if people want to go to found my fitness.com and try to figure out what,
what you've already sort of described and your verde explained,
but how does a person start?
I think a really good resource that I like is the Linus Pauling Institute.
So if you got the Linus Pauling Institute,
they are pretty good about writing a very,
it's a scientific research institute that's associated with Oregon Health
University or Oregon State and health university isn't like that,
but um,
they,
uh,
do a very balanced review on a variety of different supplemental vitamins and
vitamins and minerals and essential fatty acids and uh,
that,
that they give you both sides.
And now if they go into the Krill,
they sometimes they'll go into things like that.
And um,
but generally speaking,
I really like Alliance Pauling Institute.
It's good.
It's a good resource.
If are there places where someone can go where they can,
you know,
like say like you're just,
you're not sure what you need.
Like we were talking about various
levels of vitamins and getting them tested.
It,
is there like a standard place where you could go?
We could,
you know,
like someone who lives in the middle of nowhere can find a place and get their
blood tested.
I think one of the companies that I am familiar with,
um,
as wellness FX,
and I have no association with them other than I did a couple of guest blog
posts for them where I for free wrote about Vitamin D and magnesium and uh,
they,
they actually,
I think they're are pretty much in almost every state now where you can go onto
their website and they have a variety of different acids.
They'll do,
well,
they're measured different vitamins and minerals and omega three fatty acids.
They'll measure different things.
We'll see reactive protein and that,
and you can go to any,
uh,
enter your address and go to like a lab corp around nearest by whatever and get
your blood drawn.
And then they'll give you the data within a couple of days.
They'll help you interpret it.
They have a variety of different positions and nutritional people that can help
you interpret what your blood results mean.
So I'm like,
I used it myself.
We also got a test for my mother in law to use and she lives in Mississippi.
So,
you know,
and it's,
it's pretty much,
I think it's pretty much everywhere now.
So I really like them.
And obviously you can go to your physician and your health care,
your primary health care provider,
but they might not,
may not measure everything that you want,
like a three.
And they also might give you some of that mall you'll need to do was eat a
balanced diet.
Right?
How many times have I heard that from a physician?
It looked like shit,
you know,
like overweight position.
I mean,
sloppy,
loose skin all around.
It's free.
It's like,
dude,
you're melting,
right?
Well tell me what to do.
Yeah,
yeah.
So it,
but the wellness effects is pretty cool.
You know,
I really liked them.
But the nutrition thing,
I think it's making its way into medicine.
And that's part of the reason why people like Offit,
who is an MD,
you know,
these people,
they've been trained um,
very differently.
They haven't been trained in understanding preventative medicine,
understanding how these complex micronutrients are interacting with different,
you know,
proteins in our body and how that's important to prevent different diseases.
You know,
they,
they're have so they're not,
they're not thinking about it from the same frame of mind.
You know,
as,
um,
as people like me that are phd researchers,
our nutritionist and there's a variety of other,
uh,
I guess natural pathic doctors may be,
have more,
there's a whole variety of different naturopathic yeah.
Gets lumped into homeopathics sometimes accent different.
Yeah,
completely different.
I've been guilty of it myself.
Yeah.
I think I have as well.
I confused them in a way where the,
it just,
anything homeopathic I think of is horse shit
homeopathic,
like that crazy thing where they like dilute things to like crazy amounts where
you can't even,
there's like no act of compound if you,
if you'd Google it or look at the Wikipedia of what is decently Hormel,
uh,
sorry,
homeopathic.
They had to have their own measuring system too.
I think.
It's like they'll take a compound and they'll dilute it like a million fold and
it's like to the point where there's like no biological activity and they give
it to people.
I'm pretty sure that's the homeopathy.
I didn't realize that until recently.
Yeah.
Repeatedly diluting a chosen substance in alcohol or distilled water,
followed by forceful striking on an elastic body.
What dilution usually contains a continues well past the point where no
molecules,
the original substance remain.
Is that,
okay?
Let me tell the story.
So I recently had my wisdom teeth removed and my oral surgeon gave me this case
of pills that was Arnica.
He's like,
yeah,
nonsense.
Well,
I thought,
well no,
it was homeopathic,
which really makes it nonsense.
There is some anti microbial activity and things like that,
and Arnica,
the real Arnica homeopathic going,
it goes to like sugar.
It's water,
it's water.
Literally like,
but I didn't know his homeopathic at first.
I just thought,
oh yeah,
it's just Arnica.
And,
and it wasn't until like my husband looked at it and he's like,
do you realize this is homeopathic?
I was like,
what's that?
I didn't really,
I knew homeopathic was kind of crazy and I looked,
we looked it up and it was like mind blowing.
I couldn't believe that they were giving,
I don't even think he knows.
I think he probably made the same mistake I did where I just thought it was just
Arnica.
This is for anybody defending homeopathy,
homeopathy,
this is on Wikipedia.
Lax,
this is all with references,
lacks biological plausibility and the axioms.
Homeopathy had been,
had been refuted for some time.
The postulated mechanisms of action of homeopathic remedies are both
scientifically implausible and not physically possible,
although some the clinical trials produce positive results.
Systematic reviews reveal that this is because of chance flawed research methods
and reporting bias,
which is
pretty common.
So there you have it.
Homeopathy,
you really,
yeah,
I mean,
anytime someone says homeopathy,
they usually are wearing crystal.
They know someone who's a channel or,
right,
right.
So,
uh,
you know,
getting back to my wisdom teeth or it's a kind of a cool topic.
Um,
I had to get them removed because they were like impacted and causing problems
and pain and such.
So,
um,
I did some research.
I was like,
God,
if I have a kid,
my teeth removed,
there gotta be some kind of benefit from it.
And I found that that our wisdom teeth have something called dental pulp stem
cells in them and these dental pulp stem cells.
So this stem cell research is like a whole,
I'm really excited about the stem cell research field and where we're going with
that.
But anyways,
are our wisdom teeth have dental pulp stem cells in them that can actually form
um,
other tissues in our body,
like bone cartilage.
And they even showed recently they've,
they've taken dental pulp stem cells from people with impacted wisdom teeth,
taken them out and,
and transplant them into mice that had damaged motor neurons and it was able to
differentiate into damage mode,
like neurons,
neuronal type cells and help replace that.
So I went and looked online to see if anyone was banking them cause they do cord
blood banking where you can bank your core blood.
And indeed,
there was a company that,
uh,
it's a couple of companies that are both associated with cord blood banks as
well,
but they're,
they bank the dental pulp stem cells that you can,
when you have your teeth removed,
they send you a kit with likes buffered saline solution.
Your oral surgeon will stick the teeth in them and then they ship it off back to
the company and they preserve it in liquid nitrogen.
Um,
they kind of do very minimal processing.
They don't actually remove the stem cells that keep it in the tissue,
the dental pulp tissue,
and they freeze it in liquid nitrogen so that you can later use it if you need
it.
Uh,
so it's actually really cool because you can use this if you have damaged
cartilage bone,
possibly Parkinson's disease where you need to replace damaged motor neurons.
Um,
so I thought that was pretty,
pretty cool.
It's like a benefit for it because getting your wisdom teeth removed is not fun
at all.
It is fascinating though,
t primary teeth from children also.
So in the children's teeth,
you know,
they're losing their primary teeth and you just throw the teeth away.
Um,
they are really,
they have a really rich source of dental pulp stem cells.
So you can,
they,
you know,
your child is their tooth and you can bank it,
uh,
where you freeze it.
It's like $625 for the whole processing and then to store it,
it's like $125 a year.
I personally think it's a great investment if you have kids and they,
you know,
losing their teeth are also,
if you're,
uh,
if you have your wisdom teeth and you have to get them removed,
why not?
My daughter is about to lose her first tooth.
Perfect.
Yeah.
I'll,
the company that I went went with,
um,
I can,
I can give it to you.
I actually talked to their cell biologists.
I was on the phone cause I read through all the procedures in these scientific
papers to see exactly how you process it in the optimal way and the best way to
have the best viability after you thought them.
And so I was like getting on the phone.
I'm like,
okay,
do you do this,
do this.
And so I went with this company because I spoke with uh,
one of their cell biologist and they had done the things that I thought were the
best.
Um,
so anyways,
that whole stem cell phone,
that's cool.
Yeah,
it's,
you know,
what's really cool is that they can take fiberblast cells from your skin,
like skin cells that we slopped off like every day.
And they can add four different transcription factors,
like four different genes that they can add by like a viral ad virus to them.
And they can reprogram them to become these pluripotent stem cells in your body.
Meaning they can form any type of cell in your body.
So you can take a skin cell and you can make it,
you know,
into a brain cell,
a liver cell hearts out.
I mean this has huge,
huge implications for regenerative medicine.
But I think also just for extending lifespan,
what did you think about this latest study where they took mice and did you read
about this?
Where they took young,
the,
the blood of young mice and they reintroduced it to old mice.
Yeah.
So,
um,
that,
was that a recent study or was that,
um,
it was,
it was the recent findings because I've
seen other studies that were not super recent,
but what they did was they took like bone marrow cells that had a bone marrow
transplant and took,
which obviously bone marrow forms or blood cells from young mice and
transplanted them to old mice and the,
and the mouse,
the mice like lived longer.
Yeah.
This is,
this is recent.
It's,
um,
they,
it's from March six or may six,
rather.
They actually took an injection of young blood,
so they took the blood of,
excuse me,
they took the blood of a young mice,
they injected it into old mice and they had a tremendous benefits including
regenerating,
uh,
different,
different cells,
brain cells,
tissue cells.
Oh,
really?
Brain cells as well.
Yeah.
I mean,
it makes sense that you'd regenerate different blood populations because you
have,
you know,
stem cells,
stem cells in the blood and stuff better.
It improves
the performance of elderly mice in memory and learning tasks.
Wow.
That's pretty cool.
Crazy structural and molecular.
Please give me that paper.
Yeah,
absolutely.
that's awesome.
Yeah,
I mean this is,
this is,
this is the stuff I'm really excited about now is this,
you know,
the stem cell research and reprogramming,
we're,
the epigenetics is a really cool part where you can reprogram yourself,
uh,
to,
to basically be younger.
Um,
you know,
they're,
they're finding now that that,
so epigenetics,
I think we've talked about this a bit last time refers to changes in gene
expression and you know,
things like methyl groups and acetylation groups will sit on top of your DNA and
turn them on turn genes on and off.
But now what they're finding is they're trying to look at patterns of
methylation,
like in your DNA.
So they've,
they've already solved the human genome project where they,
and they know jeans and now they're trying to look at the,
that the methylome,
the human methylome.
And they've been able to over the past,
you know,
few years,
they've been able to identify that there's patterns of methylation in your genes
that happen with age.
And they've even been able to like systematically identify they've,
so they've taken blood from people,
various ages,
like from 19 to 101 and they'd been able to identify the age of the person,
the chronological age of the person based on their methylation patterns,
like with 96% accuracy.
And they've been able to do this like within four years.
I think they'll some before years off,
you know,
plus or minus four years.
So they can take someone's blood cells,
look at their methylation pattern and say your 50 years old and the person will
be,
you know,
50 between 50 and 54 or 46 and 50 you know,
so I think that's pretty brick and amazing that they're so,
and the thing that's really cool,
this is,
I mean,
I'm on this kick,
this epigenetics kick where they've been able to now also look at,
uh,
the cancer cells,
like in a personal take a tissue or a tumor sample.
And then a tissue from the same person,
another,
you know,
non tumor tissue,
and they'll at the methylation pattern,
they'll see that the cancer or the tumor tissue ages by like 40% based on the
methylation pattern.
Wow.
And yeah,
so it's like the cancer cells aging rapidly.
So what's really interesting is now they're looking at what genes,
these are genes,
these methylation patterns are happening around and they're finding it to like
DNA repair,
mitochondrial metabolism,
antioxidant genes,
like everything we've been talking about and this whole podcast things that,
you know,
affecting the damage and metabolism.
All of these things,
methylation patterns are happening clustered around these,
around these genes.
Um,
and the cool thing about it to me is that if we're figuring this out,
then we can figure out how to reprogram ourselves to be young and extend
lifespan.
And I really think that we're getting close to doing this.
So I mean,
if you think about,
I'll give you an example.
Like stem cells.
Stem cells also have methylation patterns that are very distinct to stem cells.
And there's certain genes that are when when a gene is methylated,
it's not being expressed.
There are certain genes that are not expressed in stem cells for a reason
because when they get expressed,
they cause the cell to stop dividing.
And you don't want your stem cells to stop dividing because stem cells are
what's repopulating the tissue.
Okay.
And they found that like a certain gene is methylated and young people,
so when we're young,
our stem cells have,
you know,
this gene is methylated,
but as we get older,
the gene,
the methylation goes away.
So there's enzymes that actually are called demethylase.
Does it take off the methyl groups and this gene becomes active and then the
stem cell like stops dividing.
It's like you lose,
you're basically losing your stem cell and then you know more stem cells,
you lose the worse off you are.
You can't replenish your damaged tissue and all that.
But what they found was that the thing that activates that thing that takes off
the methyl group is something called NF Kappa B,
which is an inflammatory,
that that thing is activated by inflammation.
And I've copied be inflammation activates NF Kappa B and then it activates this
whole pathway of demethylase,
that takeoff methyl groups.
So what I'm thinking is that inflammation is a chronic signal.
It's,
it's a way that I've been able to link environment and,
and the way,
when I say environment I just mean like damage,
constant accumulation of tissue damage,
the DNA damage.
I was talking about environment to epigenetics.
So it's like you have a chronic signal of inflammation.
It's activating these demethylase is they're taking methyl groups off of DNA and
now you're expressing genes that are usually not expressed when a,
or young in stem cells that stops the sentence stem cells from dividing.
So it's like a really cool link between,
you know,
environment and,
and epigenetics that,
you know,
as it relates to aging,
which we know that environment regulates epigenetics.
So to me it's kind of cool cause as we're figuring out these programs,
what that means is I think that we'll be able to reprogram our ourselves to
become young.
That's incredible.
How long do you think it was going to be before that happens?
I think that we're,
we're getting really close with,
I mean if you look at,
like I said with the stem cell research that we're doing now,
where we can take,
we can even take a renal epithelial cells that we excrete in our urine and make
it into a pluripotent stem cell.
We can make it become,
uh,
you selling our liver.
Um,
so I think with,
you know,
the advances we're making with that,
uh,
in combination with this learning,
the looking,
looking at fight,
figuring out the human epigenetics Epi genome,
we're,
we're looking at methylation patterns and figuring out what's happening with
age.
Um,
you know,
I think we're going to make huge strides in the next decade.
I mean,
hopefully if research a funding doesn't go down,
you know,
it's been going down the drain,
but Eisenman Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean funding is hard.
It's really hard getting,
getting funding in science because why is it
with something like anti aging,
it would sound like,
boy,
if there's something to be made where there's money to be made,
it's funding anti aging research seems like God,
that's the way to go.
Well,
there is the Nance National Institute of Aging,
uh,
funds,
a lot of the,
the aging research and there's also some private foundations that are funding
it.
But,
uh,
the reality is,
is that,
you know,
these were funding it with taxpayer dollars,
right?
I mean,
it's,
there's not a lot of money for research in general,
period.
I mean,
you'd think that cancer one would be another,
right?
I mean,
the Nass,
the,
the NCI is funding a lot of cancer research,
but the problem is,
is that it's hard to get funding and the things that are funded,
here's,
here's what I see is a big problem.
The things that are funded by these big institutes are typically things that
are,
uh,
already been proven.
They're not as creative in a,
you know,
they're the things that people feel are already solid.
So it's like,
oh,
you already published on this.
Yes,
we're going to fund you on that.
You know,
as opposed to someone that has this very creative idea,
it's very risky.
Um,
it's like,
well,
I'm not going to,
you know,
there's all these other people that are trying to compete for this money.
Giving funding for something like that is risky.
So they don't fund a lot of creative research,
which unfortunately is what makes leaps in science.
This mice thing is so fascinating because they show that after four weeks stem
cells in both the areas of the muscle and the brain kind of boost of activity
and we're better able to produce neurons and muscle tissue.
And then they also discovered that injecting the old mice or,
or rather with the young mice with old blood was a huge setback,
was a huge setback,
uh,
when conjoined to a,
an older mouse.
So the,
you know,
bringing the old blood into the new mouse,
the creation of new cells in the young mouse slowed and old blood seemed to
cause premature aging.
Yeah.
That's incredible.
It is incredible.
I mean,
it's,
but how long before people start fucking doing something gross,
like taking a person,
stealing their blood,
introducing me to their own,
stay young.
I mean,
it's really vampirism.
Yeah.
Uh,
I mean for sure.
Wait.
Now I remember that someone has read this.
I think I remember that study now.
I'm going to grab another water please.
This one right there.
Um,
well this study,
um,
it was published on,
uh,
in the Washington Post.
The article was published on May 4th.
Um,
and the study,
two of the studies published online.
The Journal of science came out.
Uh,
let's see here.
Yeah.
One of them was from Stanford,
the Stanford Group.
Well,
the,
apparently they've been working on this for quite a while,
but the results of the,
uh,
the,
the blood results have been pretty shocking to a lot of people.
Okay.
I think a lot of it comes down to,
you know,
like I said,
there's these,
if you look at the epigenome,
the methylation patterns and these stem cells,
these young stem cells,
even young cells in general,
they're very different from old ones.
Yeah.
And that affects the way,
I mean,
if you're looking at epigenetics,
we're talking about regulating a whole host of jeans,
like hundreds of different genes.
And so if these things are being differentially regulated when you're young
versus old than taking someone's young blood and transplanting into the old,
old a transplant,
he would make sense because now you're,
you know,
you're,
you're basically taking all those,
uh,
patterns that we,
that we've been able to identify and gene expression things are now going back
to young.
So it's like now you're,
you're not expressing genes that are causing your stem cells to Sundance.
You're not expressing your expressing more things that are involved in DNA
repair and things like that.
Yeah.
This is incredible.
The,
what they were able to do,
they,
they actually had more a endurance.
They navigated mazes faster,
ran longer on treadmills,
and they easily outperformed,
performed their control peers.
Okay,
awesome.
We were only given céline so it's like a definitive response.
Right.
And just,
it's such a creepy one,
I think.
But I think this is something that we can do with the reprogramming of our own,
like skin cells into like pluripotent stem cells.
Right?
And d w Yes.
Yeah.
That's,
that's really fascinating.
Okay.
And it's the same concept,
but you don't have to get someone's young blood.
You're doing it to yourself.
And how would they been able to come up with artificial blood cells?
Isn't that another thing that they've been working on?
I,
that sounds familiar.
I don't know.
Are artificial heart cells as well?
I think.
Yeah.
You know,
I just,
I'm not,
I don't remember exactly the studies and the mechanisms.
It's just so much.
Well,
although it is,
it is
difficult to get funding.
There are so many different,
yeah.
Artificial blood.
Wow.
Patient ready.
This is on,
uh,
from uh,
the-scientists.com and it's saying that a,
wow,
this is incredible.
And the myths of a news that engineered organs are being implanted into animals
and people.
Researchers announced the creation of artificial blood for transplant.
This is a very recent to April 16th.
It's nuts.
We live in strange times when it comes to these things like every day or so it
seems some new study
from somewhere in the world is popping up that shows us incredible breakthrough.
The young mice study this study,
the artificial blood story study,
if they can engineer some sort of a super potent blood and introduced into your
body.
I mean,
it's similar to like what the cyclists did when they were blood doping.
They would take their own blood,
pull it out,
injected back into their body so they had more blood or Epo,
which,
uh,
stimulated red blood cell production.
Yeah.
That,
that kind of stuff is just,
it's,
it's so trippy,
the idea of sort of hacking and retweaking the,
the components of the human body
IRA.
But I do think it's really cool.
I mean,
I know when I first,
when I first got into the biological sciences,
so I was a chemistry major in college.
I did research using,
um,
these nematode worms,
see Allegan worms,
worms,
uh,
that have like a 14 or 15 day lifespan.
And they have a lot of the same genes that we have,
but I could like inactivate one of their genes and literally double their
lifespan.
So they didn't went from living like 14 or 15 days to like 30 days.
And so this was actually,
it was,
you inactivate insulin growth signaling insulin growth factor.
And what happens is it,
uh,
this,
growth factor.
Then,
uh,
usually when it's active it,
it,
uh,
keeps the Fox,
this foxo gene,
which is a transcription factor outside of the nucleus and doesn't allow it to
perform all the functions that usually performs,
which is involved in a bunch of stress resistance like hundreds and hundreds of
genes.
And so when you'd get rid of that IGF one signaling in the worms box,
so gets activated and all of those genes and Bob and stress resistance get
activated and the worms live twice as long.
So it's like literally a genetic program in these worms that's controlling the
way the age.
So when I first,
I remember that hit me,
it was kinda like,
holy crap.
Like that's pretty cool.
Like being able to reprogram the way you age.
It's just such an amazing time with all this stuff cause it seems like we're
around at just the right time to catch this.
Just incredible perculating of all these new studies and all these new things
that are being developed.
I just,
just such a strange time to like try to pay attention to all of it and watch it
all happen.
It's so exciting.
It must be really exciting for you because this is like your field of study.
Oh No,
it's great.
I mean,
I think we're definitely going to live longer,
you know?
How long do you,
do you
think you're going to live
in my lifetime?
I don't know.
I'm going without,
you know,
without really programming.
Oh,
without you mean just that little stone erupting or asteroid impacts or,
no,
I'd like,
I'd like to be a centenarian.
That's it.
100 good with a hundred yeah.
You know when,
when,
what if a hundred comes around and they've got shit locked down where you look
like you look now at a hundred and then I could go for 200
well,
I feel like I'm happier now than I was when I was younger.
I'm smarter.
I understand stress better.
I understand
all sorts of the emotion,
right?
I understand management management of my body,
of my hormones,
management of my feelings,
management of my energy levels,
stress,
relaxation techniques to stretching,
yoga,
all that different stuff.
I feel like I'm just way happier and it said that old expression,
youth is wasted on the young,
you know,
like I understand life better.
I'm better at it now.
I'm better at being me.
It was like,
it was an awkward thing when I was younger.
I'm way more relaxed and easy with it now.
I feel like at 200 I'd be a goddamn wizard.
I wouldn't,
I would have shit down to a science.
I would have the amount of errors that I'd make as far as you know,
every,
every day average things that you fuck up,
you would fuck up almost nothing.
It would every day would be like,
you'd like to learn new things.
You could challenge yourself.
You'd constantly learning languages.
Like I never understand the people that say like,
oh,
I get bored.
I wouldn't even want to live past a certain age.
Like I don't know,
but I never get bored.
There's always new things to learn,
new things or study the new thing.
So there's,
the world is so big,
there's so much to learn.
It would be awesome to just have time to sit around and learn how to play the
piano,
learn how to speak a new language.
And I'm always sitting around reading about science,
um,
which I really enjoyed doing.
But I agree.
I mean,
there's so much out there to learn and you might get to a point if you're 200
years old,
he might've Bandon science totally.
And just fucking go down some totally different roads.
You might be a sculptor,
you might,
you know what?
You know what I mean?
I mean,
you could live several lives and still be active.
You know,
like I,
when I lived in San Diego,
I used to,
I was a surf,
I was a surfer and surf instructor and I used to sterling.
You instructed people,
I used to teach an all girls' surf school in La Jolla.
I love La Jolla.
Yeah.
I used to live two blocks from the beach side,
walk to the beach before on fire right now to see all that stuff about San
Diego.
No,
you haven't seen my family's there.
Oh my God.
San Diego's experiencing crazy fires right now.
No,
I had no idea.
Huge tornadoes of fire a hundred feet high.
Well I haven't gotten a phone call,
so that's a good idea.
I mean good sign.
Well you mean the fire departments down there on top of it because they have to
deal with this stuff every couple of years.
You know,
there was the big one a couple of years ago,
um,
I was scheduled to go down and do a show and there was these big fires and it
was so crazy.
I wound up doing the show,
but I said I had,
I donated all the money to the Red Cross.
I'm like,
I can't,
you mean there was so many people off their houses.
I just felt like it would be so gross to go down there and just make money.
Yeah.
I remember back in like,
I think it was like 2002 or something.
When we had a really big fire in San Diego and I was actually out surfing,
I was in the water and it was really weird because there were all these pelicans
and all these birds flocking to the water.
Like,
you know,
I'm sitting out on my surfboard looking out in the horizon,
waiting for the wave.
And it's like
the apocalypse,
like birds were just coming to the water,
right?
And it's like,
why is going on?
So I get out of the water and there's just ash falling.
Like,
cause my,
my car was,
I was in La Jolla shores,
the time of cars in the parking lot and there was just ash,
like all over the cars and parking lot.
But it was like the field,
that moment where I was sitting on my board and all the birds like came to the
water.
Like I had this almost like,
oh my God,
it's a nuclear warfare or something that you,
you know,
that niggery mom.
Like,
have you ever had one of those where you just get this eerie feeling where it's
like,
it's the end.
This is it,
you know?
And,
uh,
anyways,
that fire burned a lot of really close to where my dad lives.
Actually
do it it twice out here.
Really?
Yeah.
My neighborhood came really close to times,
um,
to a giant fires,
but I mean we,
we have fires that are so bad out here one time while we're doing it.
Um,
and this was the time I got evacuated.
I was filming fear factor and I drove from Los Angeles to,
to hone ranch to hone.
Ranch is about an hour and a half outside of La.
And as I was driving near Simi Valley,
which is about 40 minutes from here,
Simi Valley is where the fire kicked in.
And then four from there for the next 50 minutes of driving,
there was no fire.
Well,
when I got to work,
we started filming,
we were doing the show and then,
um,
when we were done and we left,
the fire had reached us.
So the fire had reached,
you know,
an hour of driving.
So we've talking about,
you know,
somewhere around 60 plus miles and the entire right side of the road was like a
Lord of the rings movie.
I was like,
I was expecting a demon to ride a flaming over.
It was insane for an hour,
an hour of driving,
all you saw to the right side of you was flames.
It was amazing.
The only thing that separated it was the highway and flames were jumping the
highway and you know,
they,
they had tried to keep the fire as far away from the roads and farther away from
structures.
But it was so out of control that had traveled 50 miles plus in a few hours.
I mean in a place like,
you know,
this like la or San Diego where there's a lot of dry,
brush and,
and like what kind of mechanisms do they have to,
I mean they obviously know this can be a serious problem.
Do that.
Is there any sort of like,
there's not much they can do.
I mean they try to stop it.
They,
they create fire breaks,
they drop repellents on it,
they dropped this red stuff.
That's a that that squashes the fire like in,
in certain areas.
But this fire leaps.
The problem is these things cross highways,
they are the embers fly through the air.
They land and dry brush and poof,
they're off to the races.
We're running out of time.
Um,
you wanted to promote something,
what do you got going on?
What's your iPhone APP?
I do have a new iPhone APP.
Um,
it's found my fitness and it was just released earlier this week and it's
basically you can get my podcast where I talk about my information and also I
have,
I'm a new section where I,
I gave a new new new stories and it's a community section.
If you've ever used reddit or hacker news,
it's based on that.
So it's like that.
Yeah,
that's it.
I'm trying to make an interactive community.
Um,
so if you download my podcast,
so it'd be really cool.
Right now it's new so it counts as twice a download below and also found my
fitness.com is where you can follow me.
I've got a bunch of gadgets on there.
You can click to download my newsletter.
Follow me on Twitter.
I also have a Patreon campaign where I'm,
I,
you know,
I'm giving,
I'm trying to do these podcasts and I have a couple of milestones where I'm
trying to do one talk to two podcasts a month or four.
So I'm asking people to donate or not.
It's not really donut to,
to pay to pledge 25 cents a month to help me reach my milestones that I can help
give you the context that you need and the mechanisms for how science and health
and nutrition,
all these things are interacting.
That's about as reasonable as you could ever ask.
25 cents.
I'd really,
I'd like to have a lot of people just doing 25 cents a month because it's,
you know,
it's less than a cup of coffee.
What,
one minute one minute ago.
All right,
we got what?
We've got to wrap this up.
So found my fitness,
uh,
at Twitter,
found my fitness,
found my fitness.com all the information is there.
Thank you Rhonda.
Patrick,
as always,
you're amazing.
These conversations is so enlightening and so educational.
I mean,
I can't,
I gotta go back over at 30 or 40 times to really absorb it all,
but a really,
really appreciate it.
Let's do it again.
A few months.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
All right.
Thank you to everybody tuned in.
Thanks to our sponsor.
Thank too this week.
Thanks to stamps.com use the code word,
j.
R.
E.
N.
Save yourself some money,
lots and lots of cool guests next week.
Um,
uh,
I'll tell you about them all later.
I'll see you soon.
Steve Maxwell is coming back next week.
Uh,
Alex Ross from shark works.com.
We're going to have a lot of fun.
See you soon.
Bye.